[Music]
I'm muted
myself yeah I can hear you we just I was
just I did a rolling star right now
going live can you hear
[Music]
me yes I can hear you fine can you hear
me
[Music]
yeah I can hear you give me one second
all
right
[Music]
M check mic check what's going on people
let me know how my levels are sounding
addicts in the building so was in the
building talk to me chat right quick you
know what I'm saying let me know what's
going on I see Eagles fan in there
Smitty Smith what's up Jay Bailey what's
up Anthony basz what's up yeah I see Sal
oh hustle says what's up that's what's
going on thank you thank you cool cool
Clea shano what's up man Gunstar
appreciate y'all appreciate y'all we
going to get Rolland moranda will be in
the building K will be rolling up
probably soon till we see what's up and
uh I'll talk to you guys in a actually
oh adct saw talk to hear me hello hello
hello yeah let me know if y'all can hear
them oh yeah H set attic here no doubt
my man Med said we lit what's
up no doubt so we going to cut we going
to mute it for a bit and then we get uh
Miranda in here and of course the king
going to roll through and it's going to
be an interesting Sunday in certain
topics with Sol but get ready there's
absolutely nothing
interesting he already started he
already started I already see what the
to
is all right y y already know what type
of Tom Sall we going to see what's up
[Music]
here's live chat here's a preview of Sol
and King going at it we're trying to get
the show started but they will not
[Music]
stop to help move them post oh my God K
is k s going super extra we about to go
live in one minute right and the other
person just shut
[Music]
up
hi this is Lord Sovereign from the iron
Lord podcast as you guys may recall a
few months back King David OTW announced
an amazing amazing giveaway for the Xbox
series X well I'm proud to announce that
the iron Lords podcast will once again
be giving away another console at the
end of this year and that console will
be a PlayStation 5 you heard correctly
so how do you get in on this amazing
giveaway let me explain if you're
already a member of the realm you're
good to go if you support us either on
patreon or YouTube you already have a
ballot to win this amazing console and
if you support us on both platforms you
have two ballots to win this amazing
console as you also have two ballots to
win an Xbox series X so if you're not a
member of the realm what are you waiting
for head on over to patreon.com go to
the ironlord podcast patreon page become
a member of the realm to get your chance
to win a PlayStation 5 you can also join
us on youtube/ ironlord podcast become a
member of the realm and you will also
have a ballot to win a PlayStation 5
console and if you want to support us on
both platforms you'll have two ballots
for each system to win either a
PlayStation 5 console or of course as
King David said and Xbox series X this
is an amazing opportunity that the iron
Lord podcast are so happy to bring to
our community because you guys give so
much back to us so again if you're not a
member of the realm yet what are you
waiting for go out join the realm of
either patreon or YouTube and until next
time I'll see you at the Round
[Music]
Table
h
[Music]
for
my body is oh my God my body upstairs
all right and we are live welcome to the
iron Lords podcast and the Lords of
gaming.net episode number
179 and it's another glorious Sunday
we're back at the round table on the
Lord's day I'm extremely excited about
our special guest and we've got the
PlayStation 5 tear down and backward
compatibility Rev
GameStops and Microsoft's new
partnership and Xbox FanFest to discuss
so we going to get right into it I want
to introduce a lady who not only
represents pure positivity within our
Gaming Community but with her infectious
energy and passion for multilingual
journalism is an absolute pleasure to
follow whether it be our insightful
articles detailed walkthroughs or chill
Indie streams all done in good
fun introducing the executive editor at
IGN a panelist of Podcast Unlocked and
the host of the Havoc Rose twitch
channel the lady of DOTA and all things
stationary and the only streamer who
could mitigate and arri the cat disaster
live on
air live from the Bay Area and kind
enough to make her debut into the realm
of the Lord my girl Lady Miranda Sanchez
how you doing sis
hello good morning um I am just beaming
because the introduction is just pure
gold I like can you please cck that out
so I can use them for every single thing
I do going forward I'm so bad at writing
introductions for myself uh I'm gonna
disturb the piece just because you
called out oh she actually got up oh
where's oh I have a Fluff
nice's my like a standard piece with her
she always got to have the
cater oh wow oh wow Michael Burton
salute welcome to the world put the CR
in the chat put the CR in the chat
Michael B Michael B no question so
Miranda absolute pleasure to have you in
the realm you have complete Lord at what
you do in the realm of gaming so what
what you been up to what you been
playing what's been going on with you oh
man um actually just last night I
continued my playthrough of Halo to and
I'm playing with a friend so as you know
things have been kind of stressful and
so we're just like what if we chill with
a very comfy game and so we've been kind
of replaying the Halo games and it's
been really nice to have that uh very
weird to play it on PC as always I've
been on that and been playing Spirit
fair and I've also been playing animal
crfting as you mentioned Dota 2 because
I can never give that up it will be a
for the rest of my life I'm pretty sure
but you know oh we G Talk when it comes
to like the League of Legends the doas
man I stay away from them I got destiny
in my life as it is I don't need two
cracks I got stay away for the drug
that's what's up I've I've heard
tremendous things about dude I got a lot
of questions to ask about that later
we're going to get into the show and you
know we have the Four Horsemen of gaming
those original Lords of the realm here
at the round table with our updated time
sensitive five minute intros my co-host
for the coost my brother for another
mother the difficult game conqueror Lord
of his own world and the how of the
young wolf my man Lord addict how we
doing sir you know what king it feels
nice for
him damn before I even say anything he
gave he gave him the time early d i be
Jonathan B I beat Jonathan Jonathan be
through
the you both can go somewhere with you
and all all right you know I didn't have
no smoke for you now s i was GNA let you
and King do your battle in peace now I'm
on King's side I'm all the way oning
you're not you're not helping him know
always on my side I will flip anything
you bring to the table uh so what's
going on Sir been playing Among Us I'm
exha exhausted cuz I played that a
little bit too late uh I I woke up I
heard my alarm go off cuz I what I
usually do with my alarms is they're on
the other side of the room so I have to
get up to turn them off so I said I get
up I look at the phone I was like it
can't be 10 it it can't be 10 in the
morning already it's too early oh feel
you well we appreciate you uh making the
sacrifice for Lady Miranda we appreciate
it so we keep it moving and of course oh
W oh wow did we got a something just
happened I think believe someone made a
purchase we actually new um new thing
going on with the OBS so salute to that
person I'll salute you as soon as I get
the notification later but of course we
have the most tech did he come up for
you did you see it Anonymous just
purchased a
unisex it works it works the team store
Works yo salute Nas yo thank you all
right I see it now I see it now thank
you Anonymous for purchasing it's early
early it did come up it did work okay so
of course we have our most technical
gaming Lord the solo gamer who lives for
the single player selfish experience and
also the saamus the Lord of clarity and
patreon of the iron bank Bob Lord
Sovereign how we doing sir uh uh I just
waiting for adct to jump in hold
up I have to make sure it's I can't I
can't be simplistic I have to make sure
it's unexpected and I told you you one
thing that he forgot in your intro is
you're the loser of the bets oh oh
Jonathan B said you're the Lord of
Tinder continue Lord of Tinder
that's I haven't done nothing I spent my
entire Saturday uh putting together
office furniture oh my my wife uh she
works with grants and whatnot so you
know at the end of every Grant period
you have excess money you have to spend
it yes so she went ahead and used her
excess money to purchase like three
cabinets a brand new desk and like two
chairs so she was like honey
there goes my Saturday there goes you
Saturday who who's putting it together
s that was it no doubt and I play Hades
during the week oh you play Hades all
right that's what's up that's what's up
and of course we have the Incredible
Hulk of this AKA The exess Gamer o the
prophet of Xbox King of the statues who
demands nothing less than that premium
experience it is the leader of the fraud
alert movement ooh beloved Lord King how
we doing sir straight up stroking his
ego right now check this out
turn let me see that beay bill y'all
wait a minut supposed to be
sh his name is
crazy yeah uh that's the new Kos that's
going up soon but uh She-Hulk is up so
if you didn't get a chance to check that
out go check that out uh I was uh going
over shehawk number six nice and um see
I don't do that old put them on slabs
you ain't you can't read your you know
comic books the hell with that I read my
books so I'm not into that uh new school
stuff what I was doing this week
definitely uh Destiny uh uh season of
the Fallen that uh I love I love the
Halloween joint that is so much fun yes
yes my favorite time of year for Destiny
yeah wait hold on mirand plays Destiny I
did not know this yeah I pop in every
now and then unfortunately I have too
much to do to keep up with it so season
the phone though maybe I'll go back in
and get my spooky hats last so much
money a she wants to make sure she got
the newest mask for this year that's all
PR yeah you go you get the new mask and
I'm GL I'm glad I don't have to bake
cookies so you know it's a whole lot of
fun right now you know trying to get the
different guns I just love going through
the spook the haunted forest that's so
much fun but um shout out to dealer um
because I was playing Doom
Eternal what was you playing it on Sir
why why was you playing Doom Eternal
that possible I was not purchasing the
game until game and lo and behold Phil
Dominus Maximus aelia Spencer has made
it possible for the king to play the
game and I told you I will not bend the
knee like the same way I won't bend the
knee for Mortal Kombat 11 it won't
happen so when it comes to Game Pass the
king will partake yes
he shout out to Game Pass always taking
care of King making his reluctant
purchases always worthwhile not they
control GameStop it's fun oh my God we
will get into that and of course we have
that's gonna be a messy time that's
going to be a messy time and of course
we have the gaming ninja himself the
Shinobi unlocked Lord Cognito spreading
that realness in Realm of the ILP not
telling you what you want to here but
what you need to here so shout out to
the last word this Friday my bro ebontis
we had on oh man we had on Paul tassy
man brought back yeah he was there
before yeah brought him back great great
Desy discussions I was gble to be a
little messy but one of my bets with he
Bon is that tassy was there it was kind
of funny and um yeah other than that man
I just want to thank everybody man for
all the the well wishes and everything
to Mama coog now that she's home she's
on the road to recovery you know the
love that the realm showed was was
tremendous so thank you guys it really
meant a lot she actually enjoy I showed
her some of the stuff she actually
enjoyed it so it was kind of cool
but um yeah other than that gaming wise
oh wow someone's making purchases the
store
again yes beautiful um salute to y'all
um other than that just been doing uh
like I said little Destiny fesal loss
and um out of the out of um what you
call it um out of Worlds out of Worlds
so I've been doing a lot of that and um
getting caught up as a pero for the gar
but any motivate bought a classic pull
over oh he bought the classic pull you a
get the zip dog I thought we got the new
Zips one get get get the classic pull
over pull you know the haha get Look At
You Look At You jacket shaming that
man I'm not jacket sham I like no I'm
talking to Cognito oh listen I'm a zip
hoodie guys so we finally got them I
thought those would be the ones that's
going to move n thugs where the
pullovers oh shout out hold on we got
kid Smo in the build shout out kid smoth
follow Super Chat King literally holding
out in games until they come to Game
Pass and it has worked that's right you
know why it works because I have faith
that's it who you have faith in sir I
have faith in Phil Dominus
maxus of course he did that for you of
course of course of course I
told damn D I just told him I told him
they don't believe me so cool so now we
got into what the Lords have been
playing I want to focus on Lady Miranda
her video game system history her
journey into games journalism and of
course what led her to Podcast Unlocked
and creating the amazing Havoc Rose
twitch channel so uh Lady Miranda let's
start from the beginning what was some
of the first video game systems you had
and what got you into
gaming uh so what got me into gaming was
my dad and his game systems were my game
systems for a very long time so my
parents are really young and uh when I
was itty bitty my dad's my dad had a
Sega Genesis and we would sit on his lap
as like infants so I actually have a
twin sister we're fraternal twins oh wow
so I I did not game alone when I was
small and uh we would sit on his lap
while he's playing I guess like Madden
or something one of the early versions
of some football game and I very vividly
remember him playing and there is like
an ambulance of a drive out on the field
and it was my favorite part yes it would
knock off all the players those are the
old BS yes yes old M yeah it was my
favorite thing and that's just like one
thing I remember that and that one time
that my sister got her wasn't her you
know her tonsils taken out she had ice
cream and I didn't I was very different
that play Ladd so it was okay um I don't
remember playing lad apparently it was
very very hard but my parents did uh did
get us some stuff so so that was like
very young um and so I don't really
remember the Sega too much but I didn't
actually have um an entry into Nintendo
which I think is a lot of people's first
entry until uh the Nintendo 64 so that's
when I was a bit older um but before
that though I think before that I
actually had a Game Boy Color Wow first
real love like even though I had a SE
had access to it I was so small that I
just really was play like playing with
controllers and fting up my dad's
games let me ask you just cut you one
second I got to ask you did did did Dad
do the old trick where like you would
fake like you were playing when you were
not playing or he would actually let you
play when you guys sat on his laugh CU I
remember some parents are very notorious
for that yeah so he was definitely
trying to do the trick where where we
thought we were playing yeah uh but my
twin sister is actually very smart and
she figured out how to plug in the
control she figured that we weren't
doing anything
plug controllers was
like I didn't figur that out salute that
is awesome so I'm sorry I interrupted
you say from from the color give me
those systems give me those systems that
you went from yeah so then we got our
Game Boy colors which was just so
important for me I love Nintendo
handholds like they're my favorite thing
and I'm so sad that Nintendo's kind of
moving on from that I'm just like oh but
my handhelds I have like I think three
or four DS's at this point which is the
most I've ever had of any system but
they just made them so collectible and
they're like well this version is
special for Japan or this version is
special because it only does the 2D and
it flips over and it it was too easy to
buy um so so then after um our nice time
with our our colors um we ended up
getting the Nintendo
64 and uh so that was a very big thing
for me and then it wasn't until my dad
got an Xbox that I got into to like
first person shoot well actually that's
a lie uh we used to have golden eye on
our 64 but we were so small that my mom
would hide it she's like you guys can't
play this but we
find we' find it and put it in and then
when she would come in we're like Mom
we're just making wall art we're just
shooting wall
art it's like every day where' mom hide
the
game do a scaven every day find find the
golden ey find the gold it's like she's
you you you look that way I look this
way it's funny cuz we actually got to
like significant time with it cuz I do
remember we only played the multiplayer
they're like I didn't really ever play
the campaign um but the first campaign
that I really remember getting through
aside from like Pokemon was uh ocarine
of time that was like my first like
really big Cher game that like Mario 64
like very a lot of Classics and those
were really big for me as a little
kid but I think my my path changed
when my dad [__] Halo
oh dad was a gamer game alike he was
yeah he so these consoles were all his
they were not mine they were not bought
for us except for the uh Game Boy colors
like those were for us but my dad was
the one bringing sounds like King's
household that's for
you yeah we're sitting you with these
over here um got more time with other
things so uh so my mom of course like
she was like you know these are like
kind of violent they shouldn't be
playing these but my dad he wanted
someone to play Halo with so Dead's like
he knew that I love video games like my
sister was in games but not not the same
level that I was he's like mirinda
mirinda mom's
out her but I'll let you play Halo with
me let's go
okay and it's like one of my favorite
games of all time and it's like such a
huge thing thing for me wow as far as
like like a formative like that was like
my first like narrative firstperson
shooter experience like since I never
really got to experience like what gold
I was and so that was so important
because I love first person shooters and
like Halo is so iconic and like having
that be the first one was was pretty big
for me that's huge yeah and so from
there like I always talk about this
unlock too it's like Fusion frenzy nice
on the original Xbox it's huge for me I
wish they' remake that or do something
with that friend got it just backup pet
looks fantastic it looks like a game
play the old stuff okay I looking new I
love the Nostalgia of looking that old
game but also if they would remake it I
would not complain cuz those water
levels are
trash if you look at like experiences
that we've had now like I wouldn't call
Among Us like that type of game but it's
like a party game Fall Guys party game
like clearly there's a market for it but
you know the only people that's really
collecting on it's Nintendo and they do
it H half ass so yeah I don't want to
play Mario party again I really don't
like I'm done give
mezy no D so Halo that what an
introduction so you're rocking that so
so what give me some more of those
titles and then from what more of the OG
Xbox title did what else did you
transition to console yeah so I remember
uh we played Mech Warrior I don't
remember which one but it was like one
of the earlier ones I remember the cover
and I always forget which which number
it is or like what the actual title of
is so Mech Warrior is pretty big for me
Al had amped we had uh Project Gotham
Racing oh I love Project Gotham with the
Kudos remember the Kudos the Kudos oh
that was my game continue that was a
good time so my mom also plays some
games like she's not as intense as other
people um but she does play some so she
loved racing games that's when we would
play together so that that was nice so
Mom did play though that's kind of cool
she loves Mortal Kombat what hold on
hold I got I got I got to put fraud on
mom for a second so she didn't allow you
guys to play the shooter games but she's
playing Mortal Kombat I mean she she was
a grown woman so I think that had more
to do with but she's playing in front
she playing Mortal Kombat in front of
the kids play in front of us oh okay
okay oh I like this but
she want us to play they was peing
through the crack
inanda fatality mommy did a
fatality salute salute so then from
there you at OG SP you got so what was
the next transition for Dad system wise
or you system wise so so the next thing
I think we got was we got a
GameCube um and we didn't have too many
games that one yeah Luigi's Manion was a
big one for us Super Mario Sunshine I
had one of the animal crossing games on
there I had a few other games on there
as well um and I really loved our
GameCube we actually had this Disney
Party game not Mario party we did have
Mario party I think eventually but
there's this Disney Party game that they
had on there so good I always play with
those with my my siblings that's what's
so we also have younger siblings as well
so there was four of us growing up so
party games are a pretty big deal for us
that's awesome Mario party was a great
game it's just like they didn't keep
evolving throughout the time it's like
that g there's no reason that don't have
online functionality in 20 nintend
nintend we're not we're not say I'm
tired of people saying this is Nintendo
and acting like that's an excuse that is
not an excuse we didn't say it was an
excuse we just telling you
who you dealing with exactly
exactly let's get these super chats let
me get this one let me get this one okay
so we got a $2 Super Chat from uh Lord
KATU Miranda played uh GBC so I'm
assuming Game Boy Color he's more OG cry
uh than more OG credit than addict
mangle bro mang it's not my fault he
could have spelled it better but you
know it is what it is you know first off
I had the Game Boy Color so you can you
can take that go somewhere with it cuz I
play Pokemon on it so I I don't know I
remember putting the little light things
in the Game Boy Color because I time
back to the Super
Chat the light it didn't have a backl
on only do AR with KATU time back to the
super chats man he was getting that work
he was getting that work $25 Super Chat
I'm so happy MOG is doing well so heal
and Recovery and Recovery brother we
have Jonathan B with the $5 Super Chat
Miranda skeleton randomly changes
positions like kings Mario also
time and then we have a regulator 951
with $2 Super Chat good morning Lords
and welcome queen of fusion
frenzy salute salute makes so happy
morning hello everyone in chat I see
your chats by the way I'm
watching telling a
story
she's lowkey say behave I'm watching so
s we we all caught up we're all caught
up Okay cool so back back to so again
GameCube now so did um yeah from there
like did we do um any PlayStation at all
or like or we just stayed kind of Xbox
or Nintendo so so my most of my exposure
of PlayStation was playing at friends
houses so we just never really got the
original PlayStation but I do finally
remember playing Spyro at my friend's
house um and all the while also I'm
keeping up with the Nintendo handhelds
like I had a Game Boy advanced I had a
special Target red Edition red was my
favorite color was very important for me
we got New Mexico on a trip and I was
just I was just so
happy eventually I also got a DS as well
nice um but yeah so my exposure to
PlayStation was mostly through friends
until Kingdom Heart so addict is in love
now here we go he's look at him look at
him look at that smile look
Smiles they always be making fun of me
over my Kingdom Hearts though always
I've never seen this smile before this
man is excited
continue no one else has ever said they
like Kingdom Hearts on the show
like so so get this I had to like save
my penni it's like I had to save all my
money I believe it was fourth grade when
I got it and I was just like all right
birthday money is in the bank I at my
fourth grade Fair there is an auction
for a PS2 wow I want it cuz all I want
to do is play Kingdom Hearts and the PS2
is the only thing that has it so I have
to get it and I remember as a kid too
like the cutcenes really fooled me
because I from a little kid and I didn't
know it was different I was like why
does why does the PS2 look like that
whereas my Xbox looks like this what's
up and then until I got it and I was
like oh it's the same
thing
Liars I didn't actually know that that
wasn't gamepl cuz I was so small and
it's it's kind of funny like thinking
about how how you see things through
different lungs when you're smaller MH
um but yeah so so I save my pen use I
actually did not get the PS2 at that
auction I backed out oh you backed out I
did not so I backed out uh but I did
eventually go to gam stop later and
bought it with my own money I was so
proud that was the first system I bought
with my own money oh that's awesome that
is awesome it always feels good with
that like that first purchase you make
for yourself like it's that's pretty
awesome so we got to salute wow some fs
and everything there so did we uh
transition to the uh 360 at all or yes
eventually we did get a 360 um but also
we had a PC so my house was just like my
my parents were very big on dising and
getting into things so like a lot of the
stuff we got were like usually later
into the generations uh and also like I
don't think I ever got it I didn't get a
day one
console ooh until maybe the Wei maybe
and even then I don't think that was day
one okay think I got a a launch console
with the
we I don't even want to
talk that's a great console I don't care
what nobody I was I moved my furniture I
was all I know is sky sword was on that
ruin the whole oh my don't start don't
you two start with that I'm not saying
anything time get him
King no doubt moving on so get the PC
cuz I we had a PC I think my PC is
mostly for like my dad for work because
he's an IT guy so he worked in American
Ain it fellow it yeah yeah he was in the
Navy for that originally and like went
to school for all that so then he got a
job and all that and so it's like he's
always messed with the computers I just
like yay I can watch him play Call of
Duty over his shoulder even though I'm
not supposed to be I definitely did I
remember that's that was my first expion
to Call of Duty as well was him playing
on PC which is like ohd thinking about
that anyway miss my dad the
dad
yeah yeah and so uh eventually we got
our own PC time in the form of the Sims
so that
was somewhere that's that is a life
drainer it was we were allowed to play
that except the robbers used to scare me
like that the music would come on and I
just freak
out they have like creepy fure back then
they don't have like the robbers anymore
which is kind of a weird thing that they
removed as an event mhm uh because it
was scaring kids they just have they'll
just have people randomly come up and
take your stuff now then just get
abducted by aliens like it's it's good
time it's good time good stuff good
stuff no doubt the only tragedy is they
can climb out of the pools now you can't
yeah yeah yeah okay that's over with
it's pretty bad it's probably it's
probably for the best so one one game
that you are synonymous for on FSC PC
that didn't mentioned yet is uh DOTA I I
need to know that I need to know about
that that whole story that love affair
yeah oh my God DOTA did not come until
way later that was actually a college
thing okay um so do we want to see want
to skip forward no no I mean it's up to
you you could transition through or you
could go straight what it's it's up to
you okay we're gonna take we're going to
take a little DOTA pit stop
okay go she's so excited
about guys I have so many hours in Dota
I'm pretty sure it's I don't know you
guys might have more hours in Destiny
than I do in DotA who knows I I would
say yes yeah we're probably probably
there yeah except for sof EX for how
wait how many hours on average do you
have wow on average you know what Sam in
the destiny Community if you don't have
at least 2,000 you're considered a scrub
you're like a casual that's fine I I
could see that I have 2,671 hours on
Dota 2
wow yeah that's she's checking her stats
right salute salutely um so I've been
playing since
2013 um so I got into that actually
after League of Legends surprisingly
enough I started League of Legends
playing by myself um I got like my
partner at the time into it and then
eventually my one of my friends was like
hey you should play DotA too and I was
like but I play a league and he's like H
listen like I'll I'll play a league with
you if you play DotA with me I was just
like okay that's how it starts that's
how it starts yep you know who never
played give you the first the first wait
wait she never played league with you
actually you agreed no he never played
league with me he never played
League the setup salute to the setup
bait
switch he's like oh that's that's that's
like a little animal that gives you your
stuff of the shop and I was like what
wow just remembering that he didn't end
up his she she texting him right now
with her off hand oh I did it with
someone Shi he
know salute salute um and so like
eventually I just uh moved on just to
DOTA like DOTA became a full-time I
found out like I liked DOTA a lot more I
think they're both very great yeah mobas
for different reasons it's it's a lot
like comparing like Battlefield and Call
of Duty like they're very different
games they may be in the same John run
through the same kind of game but they
are not the same game in any sort of way
and they have like kind of merits that
really stand out for them like for
instance I'm a Call of Duty person where
my dad is a battlefield person which is
very weird um dad's the smarter one oh
Lord wow wow the disrespect to the guest
D you were doing so good at it star to
like you oh it's over relationship's
done the bushes it started at Kingdom
Hearts and died at Call of
Duty dut R all
the
you oh my god y Savage Oh my
God
that's your game that's your game no
doubt continue so yeah so that's
actually good transition so I actually
didn't get my started Call of Duty until
of course 360 which I think is where a
lot of people did um I I was really a
big halo person of course and uh so we
got a 360 I don't know when I just
remember my parents wouldn't get me
Gears of War and I was really jealous
because my high school boyfriend had it
and he would just play Gears of War I
was like that couldn't be
me pissed
Sal Could Have Been Me cold
world was a hell of a commercial what a
trailer what a trailer that definely
that definitely sounds like a good
commercial like see that could be me
hold on Yo shout out to Nintendo girl
real M you said can we replace adct with
Miranda permanently
now if you want Call of Duty people in
this podcast maybe I should I should
walk out the back door and just be how
you going to hit with those people the
Call of Duty people you know what it is
it's like Call of Duty is a big budget
Michael Bay film that's how I I I see
right and Battlefield is more like a
what is it like a foreign film at this
point Call of Duty might as well be fast
in the fear oh my god listen we cannot I
got Mand I got to defend you cuz Call of
Duty changed the game when it when it
changed the game but it hasn't changed
since it changed the game it has it it
went away from exactly it was but it
always you know what every year Call of
Duty would give you a new technique
bi don't don't be upset we a say time
when you was all going crazy over your
your your
kingdom he
wasting belting over Kingdom Hearts you
see his eyes y adct smile yo Miranda
adct does not smile on IOP like was two
smiles when Kingdom Hearts came out I I
was very listen listen to the dis
justtin his voice when he said Kingdom
Hearts he he referred to it as that
Kingdom Hearts oh my God that what's up
S real quick you want to get the super
chats let's just catch up real quick
then we continue mirand we have aamus
with $2 Super Chat Miranda Boomer Sooner
let's go I don't you lost me Oklahoma
Oklahoma Oklahoma someone knows the
history I went to University of Oklahom
so oh says like Boomer you say sooner
and
so salute what did they research
then we have Gerald Mack with the5 ch
good morning Lord shout out to the
special guest Miranda Sanchez oh thank
you then we have Clifton coffee with the
$5 Super Chat welcome to the realm Lady
Miranda shout out from the OKC Lord that
like button to power your dreams and the
podcast thank you salute salute power
your dreams see what you're doing
there if you guys are in Oklahoma please
uh maybe check out Van's pigstand
sometime soon because I miss a dear
yearly that is like the one thing in
Oklahoma I miss I left literally the day
after I graduated I was just like
byea I don't want to be anymore I was I
yeah I was born in Oklahoma City and uh
my my parents both with to you and
that's why I went there
and and I don't like going back oh
wow wow I don't have any family there
anymore either so I don't really have a
reason to it's
just it's
place in the bushes
there that are really cool there are
there are spots that I like a lot and
things that I like about it but
generally it's just like man it is work
that was a side step from the initial
statement to go to Oklahoma than it is
for me to go to Hawaii like
put wow so so y'all know she will not be
coming back on Flag
Day Flag Day has officially been
cancelled is Miranda showing up this
Flag Day father no she will not be
showing up oh my God salute
salute s you want to finish off off we
have one more yeah we have one more we
have Jonathan B with the $5 Super Chat I
legit didn't even know addict had teeth
until he smiled for the first
time you a truthless Wonder oh my god
let's welcome to the realm qti Grizzly
thank you sir qti Grizzly salute salute
welcome what did it for you Grizzly was
it the PlayStation 5 that your show
trying to get oh my God I know King got
four of them I'm getting one hold up
just real quick kid smooth if you're
still in the chat send me that link on
that PlayStation thing you just said I'm
gonna send that to King gotta give him a
little bit of hmer so moving
on to Iron Mike in the chat for talk
about Bricktown I did very much like
Bricktown oh Bricktown that's what's up
some some OKC talking here that's that's
what's going on so actually a good
transition um you know basically you
know obviously we got good great amazing
gaming history and stuff like that but
what kind of got you into games
journalism like what was the whole
passion behind that like how did that
transition start so it was fifth grade
it was fifth grade when I decided that I
want to get into ring B video games for
my profession that that was it and then
I shot straight forward I did every
single thing I could to get into like
writing classes or journalism going to
like journalism camps going to school
for journalism freelancing and then I
got my job that was like that's the
short of it I was like very very
determined to just do this job I did not
want to do any other jobs um so when I
was a kid I really hated reading until I
read Harry Potter which is a problem now
but you know I still really love Harry
Potter um and so so that was the first
book that got me into reading and then I
was like wow I want to write books and
then I was like you can't make money
writing
books that and so of course I to another
thing where you don't make money which
is writing about video
games got to make that money yeah I mean
it's for the books probably like you're
probably better off um and so or you
have a better maybe I don't actually
even know I don't know this T that um
and so so I love video games so much and
I always knew that I wanted to do
something with it so that's where that's
where I came into and uh so how did that
IG yeah yeah so I I seriously just every
single class every yearbook Club I could
join every like journalism class I could
take I always went through that as much
as I could just to kind of get into it
and of course like keeping up with uh
video games where I can you know like
that's that's oh up that's Ari that was
Ari I Cannonball of fluff that was Ari
yeah salute salute to Ari out here going
to the lit
box probably she's chasing her sister
Morty but they're not actually sisters
but I call them
sisters uh so so yeah and then
eventually so where I got my start with
IG was actually as a fan so I was
actually back in the day a moderator for
the unlocked Facebook group was really
weird so I was a very big fan of that
show before I got to IGN wow and and I
liked U Beyond and everything else like
I got a Vita and I was so excited about
it salute to the
v such a great console a little handh
yeah I love that handh yeah except the
fact that you had to buy the memory card
the proprietary stuff my mom my mom and
dad didn't know that you had to buy a
memory card so I couldn't even use it
when I got it for birthday they're like
here you go like here's a game it's like
I need a memory card like we can take
you to GameStop I like
okay salute I had to buy that part
salute that's that's that's a fair
tradeoff you bought me the system I'll
buy I bought him my B card fair enough
so you again you're you're doing the
moderation for um unlocked and you are F
this is amazing story continue continue
I want to know how this transition Happ
yeah absolutely so I was a very big fan
and so again I was into uh some
PlayStation stuff as well with Beyond so
I actually got to meet all the IGN
people so like of course my sites were
more set on IGN right um and I got to go
to Beyond 300 I was like I have to go
like this is my only chance to meet them
like when else would I meet people from
my like this is my in and so I saved up
my money I worked a lot of uh parttime
jobs in college and I uh managed to get
a ticket to beond 300 and a flight and
so I got to go to San Francisco for the
first time I fell in love immediately
and I got to meet everybody I was trying
not to be like fan girl I like oh my God
you do this
professionally your people this is your
dream if anyone used to listen to uh
unlocked back in the day uh Mitch dryer
was one of my favorite hosts on there
and he's actually one of my super close
friends now which is really weird when I
got my first email from him I remember I
remember where I was I was in uh like
the the magazine room essentially of my
journalism school and and I got a reply
from him from a question from unlocked
and I freaked out I was like oh my God
he know
speak salute salute to the reply causing
the feelings yes never
know salute shout out the [__] and so
yeah so actually getting to be him them
in person was pretty huge because
somebody just got to be Pals nice so and
so then from there I was like you know I
really want to work here eventually when
day like that'd be really cool like okay
well you know just get into freelance
when you can like obviously you're
already going to journalism school
that's that's huge you already write I
actually had my own gaming podcast at
the time it was called random Havoc nice
uh a quiet fact about me some people
some people actually were around from
that they're like I remember the random
Havoc do was like
what excuse you so yeah I started my own
blog that I also did parttime in
addition to like you know working and
doing school work where I was just
really trying to like write my own
reviews and I remember one of the first
game codes I actually received was for
um State of Decay that was my first
getting a game review and that like
meant so much to me and I don't think
anybody else really knows that ex say
like a quiet exive chist game for a very
specific reason and so I was like yeah
really trying to grind it out like to
show that I was super interested by
doing my own thing and my mom uh she
used to do stuff for Pinterest and
Consulting for social media on Pinterest
m for different businesses and so she
knew all about like SEO and blogs and
all these things so she really helped me
get it set up that's huge that's huge
yeah yeah and so so from there I kind of
talked to every I even like made my own
business cards and stuff I was just like
oh that so cute back then that's awesome
good so then what what was the moment
when it's like okay we're offering you
you know a position like what what that
exact moment you remember that that old
sequence yes I do um so really quickly
what led up to that was about a year of
freelance so every now and then I will
publish a post about looking for new
Freelancers especially for news because
they try to have a we try to have a good
pool of news Freelancers because that's
the stuff that turns around the most I
me people who are a little bit more
available yes and so as soon as I saw
that go up like you have to fill it an
application you have to submit um kind
of a demo of stuff so like they'll give
you a prompt it's like write new stories
for these three like press releases like
how do you interpret them and how you
make that they're you story uh so I
applied immediately and I was like
please please please please please and I
got it I was like thank God and Mitch
and Andrew hired me on for that for
their little team and we were a hungry
group of Freelancers at the time nice
and I remember my first article that
went up to it was about some like mobile
game sale which is a very weird article
but you will proud you were proud when
it went up y that was my first article
on
IGN yeah and so I did freeny for them
for a while eventually transition into
helping with features because I was like
give me more work like what can I do and
then I pitched Dan on reviews had my
first panic attack when he gave me my
feedback for my first
review oh god I've never seen a paper so
red oh shout out to the editorial
team we we're familiar at Lord G that
that our editors send back a lot of
stuff in red needs to be redone but I
know I know what you mean continue it's
good right like you want to see that
though because that mean someone's
actually like sugesting your work and
wanting you to get better and so I had a
panic attack I thought I was never to
get a job I like they hate me they will
never give
me there were errors oh no
yeah after that I I I worked on it I
submitted it it got published and then
he gave me another review I was
like that's what's up that's what's up
that is awesome from there what really
got me on my my path though and kind of
what got me my job was working on guides
yes so Dan Dan Stapleton who still is
our reviews executive editor referred me
to Sam Clayborn who at the time he was
still my boss actually uh he referred me
to him for writing guides he's like oh
it's easy like if you want to do some
guide for here's here's what you do and
so that's when I started working with
that guides team and I had not really
written guides before and I fell in love
immediately it is such a cool kind of
style of writing that you don't
necessarily see in a lot of other things
yes um and So eventually I was getting
ready to graduate so I graduated half a
semester early because I wanted to
I wanted to graduate early so I took
like summer classes and stuff and I did
like stuff in in high school so I had
passed a few of those exams they and had
some extra college credit and I was like
if I if I just work hard enough I can
graduate early wow this is awesome get
me out of here no salute salute to the
Grind salute to your grind that is
that's a big deal I'm not going to let
you poo poo that like you really went
extra hard to to achieve your goal and
you you wanted to finish early so salute
this sacrificing the summer and just
like go going for it like that's a big
deal I appreciate that yeah thank you I
for me I'm like very determined like I
will work as hard as I need to to get
something done like I will just I will
go at it like I will find I'll formulate
a plan I'll write it out I'll try my
best to make it happen and um I think
especially for me like my college
experience was weird because I was very
much about like just getting stuff done
I only went to very few parties I mean I
had friends but I did marching band I
had some Hobbies but I was really mostly
about getting worked done I kind of
regret that a little bit but Ryan we had
Ryan on Ryan said the same thing he said
the same thing as you he said uh he
respect it got him to where he he is now
he he had to grind but there's a part of
him that looks back and says well maybe
I should have just enjoyed it a little
bit because you only get that moment
once but then again you guys wouldn't be
as as great as you are you know so it's
like it's that the sacrifice that you
know you guys been I want to shout out
two of our writers in the chat uh shout
out to my man Jean Lord Jean scribe of
the month and a for scribing them up now
at window Center Jared they loved your
walkthrough segment they love they the
guides they they yeah they really
appreciate they they they do guys
themselves so shout out salute to our
team but yeah so you you grinded it and
then continue I'm sorry I interrupt you
you you did the sum please please ask
any of all questions I'm just like going
through the so please I feel bad talking
so much is your moment so yeah this is
your story so continue okay so yeah so I
start I got started with with guides um
and still doing other freelance work I
was working for Justin Davis when he ran
features for a long time still doing
newswork still doing reviews and um
eventually a job opened up at Ian
specifically for guides but it was not
only guides but it was also editorial is
their first half and half roll and Sam
like hey we haven't listed this yet but
I would like you to apply for this I was
just like let's go Qui job but not like
we still have have to list it but please
apply for
this salute salute okay yeah and so it
just so happened that I had actually
because I had just turned 21 so what I
wanted to do for my 21st birthday was to
go to San Francisco and so I had like
saved up all my all my part-time job
money like I worked at a little cafe on
Camp like near campus and I was like all
right saving my pennies doing my
freelance pennies I want to go back to
San Frisco and see all my friends at I
and so I did it just so happened that I
was just literally after I applied I was
at the airport telling him like I
applied also by the way on my way to San
Francisco just in case you want to do an
interview just in case you
know you know I'm in town I'm in town
you know my application there I I'm in
town so you know we want to do this
right now prob think well man I just
told you to apply I didn't say you got
the
job I respect I respect the hustle Randy
I respect the hustle that is crazy I
love it continue continue yeah so it was
kind of insane that it it lined up that
way like I did not expect it I had the
trip planned well before that they had
uh said that they're opening that
position so I went out um but you wrote
down right because you said that you
write things down you visualize it and
then you go and achieve it right so you
wrote that down did you write that plan
down before it happened um I I had
planned out going there and hoping to
like work in the office so sometimes
what happens when we have Freelancers in
town we let them come like set the
office with us if they like to or like
whatever that so so I wanted to go do
that and I was like oh that'll be fun
and I just want to go celebrate my
birthday with my friends at the time my
twin sister so we actually lived
together we're really close uh she was
studying abroad in Japan at the time
because she got like an opportunity for
that and so I was just kind of living my
living alone I was like what am I going
to do for my 21st birthday by myself so
so that's why I had planned to go to to
San Francisco and I figured I'll go
celebrate with my friends from my but
also you know uh celebrate from other
friends who live in San Francisco and
maybe go work in the office and like
make my face no a little bit more like
meet these people that I'm working with
that I've been working with for a while
and maybe that'll that'll help along the
line um so that was kind of part of the
plan I did not plan the whole I'm
applying and I guess you guys could do
the introductory interview instead of
over the phone I'm already there
right great yeah so that I think really
worked in my favor and I was so nervous
because that was my first like major job
interview like I'd only worked in places
that were like smaller like like kind of
mom and pop chop that I had known or
like I had gotten to know a little bit
better before you know getting the job
and so going up and like being the
editor and chief I was so worried I was
like oh my God I gotta be professional
I'm so nervous like I've been working my
whole life for this I cannot mess this
up can't mess it up I mess it up so I
got I'm sorry I Contin you oh yeah yeah
so so I got the job and uh that's
awesome I had to go so they actually I
had to fly back out again later for
another interview with almost literally
everybody I don't think we don't really
do this the same way anymore but there
were like six rounds of interviews wow
it was whole day Affair like you meet
with engineering you meet with like the
the top of IGN you meet with like two
halves of the editorial team you meet
with product you meet with everybody and
they really get to know who you are
before they say you can come in no
that's that's awesome I me you know like
I said part it's part of the process you
know it's intense and one thing I liked
is you know you put the work in and I
love like what king said like you kind
of visualized it and put yourself in
position I'm a heavy uh person into that
spelling thing because I believe that uh
you uh write your own path so when you
write it down you make it real yeah you
see it and then once you see it then you
can achieve it you gotta you know
visualization is a a key step and a lot
of people like to side step that step
but if you do it you are more likely to
achieve your goals and like everything
I've been hearing you've been talking
about uh you you you wrote it down you
made your plan you saved your money you
and that all started from the structure
that you had like the structure growing
up Mom and Pop the structure growing up
you saved you saw him having this you
couldn't wait till you were able to do
it right so and you just grew all the
way through so in going to college of
course you weren't going to go and party
and stuff like that because you had a
goal and a plan in mind you had your
business cards already so like your
Focus was laser going all the way
through so of course you were going to
go to uh San Francisco and yeah you know
what I submitted my application but you
know while I'm here I can do interview
and I'm pretty sure that impressed a lot
of people that was there pretty and I
love the fact that uh one thing she
mentioned is like it's like a game an
awesome gaming household you know just
like Mom and dadd there so much
involvement and you know that is so cool
to see you know cuz let's be real you
know a lot some parents you know they're
not as invested in in the kids if they
want a career in gaming or may not see
gaming as something as a as a future
right but your story is so cool you had
mom helping
on the vogs and stuff that's like that's
kind of crazy know yeah I was very
fortunate for that like and think you
guys I I really appreciate sometimes I
discount like the oh I was lucky that I
also know that I worked I worked like
hell to do yes yes you did it's a lot of
distractions out there and for you to
block out those distractions it takes a
lot you know because at those times
especially when you're going to college
you meet new people and you're doing
this and you're doing that and to save
Focus you know oh it's hard yeah we
can't that especially you know young
adults partying fun you know it's
supposed to be a fun period of life but
to to have the discipline right to to
stay in it is huge but I want to I want
to transition you know obviously to
where most of the realm is familiar with
you is uh podcast are a lot you know and
obviously we had the amazing Lord Ryan
Caffrey on here in the realm and
obviously I got a chance to to guest and
be there with you guys which was
absolutely awesome thank you for
shouting out the iron Lord gear that was
that was very we very appreciative I
felt good when you said she was like I
like your girl I was like yes it is so
good it's so so good like I love how all
of your sisters just like so decked out
with it too like the logo is fantastic I
was watching like this the shows before
and I was like man you guys have it just
on point it's thank you so means a lot
to us thank you so much see our logo
everywhere at this point yeah that's
fantastic appreciate it so obviously you
know and of course um you know Dy legary
and my man Brandon Tyro I got a chance
to meet both of those as well but uh how
did that start like how did you know
your introduction to podcast a lot begin
so that actually started like a little
later on into my career at IG and I
forget how many years I had been there
like I had guessed it on unlocked every
now and then but they kind of had a set
crew for a while until some people
started leaving um and so yes yeah I was
like
I
lovebox you guys want to have me on she
like I like Xbox
hello be very honest someone just left
and she just sent the email well I'm
available that day I'm just saying be
honest Miranda be honest Miranda talk
talk to talk to the people about
it so I did have my own show before
unlocked um and which is why sometimes I
think Ryan lets me
host I used to have our anime show so I
brought I brought anime with new Force
TI that was part of my pitch for my job
I was like I love anime you're doing it
wrong let me show
abute fix that anime up IA let's go yeah
so I pitched a show uh which
unfortunately got canceled after a while
uh for silly reasons but that's okay the
people who did that are gone
but yeah it's so so I had some like show
experience which was good and so then
Ryan was like hey do you want to be like
a permanent member of unlock was like
like look at her
face yo that face was classic
Miranda he's talking to her y that face
was classic I'm
sorry so I will say I will say like I
never really get imposter Syndrome from
things like because I know how hard I
worked I know like how much I've been
doing and like I think I only know that
because a lot of people have told me and
like I I always really appreciate people
point that out it's like you you earned
this it's like thank you um I think it's
there's a lot pressure to say like well
you just got lucky or like you're really
lucky and like people say that a lot and
I am certainly lucky for things but I do
try to like keep that in perspective of
like how much I did work for it yeah um
and thankfully again I have a lot of
mentors around me who have been really
intense about that it's like you ask for
what you want like do what you need to
because like these people won't just
reward you for good work like you have
to ask you have to put yourself out
there and it's really diff difficult and
different from what you grew up with
maybe um
so when it comes to online locked
because I was such a huge fan at first
because like I was a moderator and I
hosted like gaming events and I met a
friend through unlocked who's still my
friend today ni uh super close friend
actually um getting on that podcast
meant a whole lot to me like that meant
even though I was like obviously doing
my job I had been promoted a few times
now I run our guides team like that's
that's a very big deal but when I come
to unlock I'm just kind of like oh my
God the first time I hosted it I was so
nervous guys I was so nervous I was
like ah this is the show I love so much
and now I'm hosting it this is your
moment girl it's your moment yeah
terrifying I I've done so many things
and it's all meant so much to me but
like getting there was just like just
like the smack in the face reminder of
like man you did it you did it girl you
did did it preach it preach it preach it
girl you did it so I get really worried
it's like I hope the community likes me
like I hope they enjoy me being on and
thankfully people seem to and I see all
like the very kind messages in chat by
the way so I really appreciate it and oh
yeah yeah I think especially growing up
as like a woman in gaming especially as
a young girl you get so much [__] you
get so much on especially in Call of
Duty so adct to your
point hold hold up hold up I didn't
attack no
no I didn't attack anyone in specific
about Call of Duty I attacked you all as
a ho I don't
discriminate no but it's it's a good
point and um yeah I believe that uh luck
is a byproduct of hard work you know you
make your own luck you know you can't
get lucky if you don't try if you're not
actually putting yourself there so you
know luck is a byproduct of hard work
and you know the fact that you put in
the work you made your own luck so
absolutely I mean like I said super L
there on podcast Lu we love the energy
the fun you know what I'm saying always
having a good time always smiling and
then I noticed now you transition the
the Havoc Rose Channel now you got
stationary streams and and all the Indie
chill nights and all type of cool stuff
going on so like what what made you now
say okay you know what I want to do my
own thing too so this has been a plan
for a very long time to just do
streaming on the side just for fun um
for a while at IGN that was not a thing
you were really supposed to do just
because of the whole kind of funny thing
which right uh I actually came on to I
oh hi
Ari like calling at me um I came on like
right as they were leaving like just as
they had announced that they were doing
their own thing um because essentially
they were competing with you know IGN
and at that point which is a little
tough um and so that was always weird I
always shed away from it until a lot of
like the turnover and like hire staff
happened and we had people who kind of
understood like the value of us having
our own outlets for our own creative
success and just doing what we wanted
it's like as long as you're not
competing directly with IGN yeah awesome
why not that's awes do your thing that's
awesome uh so I had always had like I
got in Elgato like a year and a half ago
like and no not Elgato sorry the stream
deck the little mini stream deck for a
while stream oh one of the first things
I streamed funny enough was
Destiny Sal Salo let go she made up for
the Call of Duty slander
thing back not in my book no
no fell out with Sal
now that's okay that
F it's fine he's over there oh my God
s's just still upset he lost the bet oh
my God I'm so excited to get into this
part this gonna be
good she ready ahead of this it was it
was very you guys are in for a tree
chat anyway so I got into a streaming
just because I've been home a lot like
honestly I get kind of lonely and it's
kind of hard just being
here so like audience now to dream and
that is so much I've been well adct and
I do this little thing like sometimes
we'll play a game because me you know
soft is not tell oh lot of soft slander
today he's not Dependable my God no well
to finish a game with you you know he's
your friend but he do oh
my adct came in and he saved me right
what was that game um it was remember
the
game so it was so important to first I
was gonna say get out and that's a movie
so anyway I didn't want to say that so
the chat roast it's called way out and
that game was so much fun you know and I
think they should do more games like
that especially if you only can have one
copy I really think he EA didn't like
that all right so but the game was so
much fun and me and St made it to this
one part and we never finished it and it
was bothering the hell out of me so but
I thought the Stream did really well and
the fact that you were able to do that
and you bring in people and they're
talking and you can see that the the
they writing stuff and you know in the
chat and they're saying like do this
touch this so you're not
alone I me to say that like sometimes
I'm in the living room by myself but I'm
playing with my friends and we're all
there you're not alone absolutely I feel
like there's a lot of people that they
see like streaming and stuff and they're
like oh that's easy oh you just you just
talk in a mic like people don't realize
like how hard it is to maintain a chat
to maintain your well you know the
energy that you're bringing into the
into the actual stream to to maintain
you know if you get any type of uh you
know support from the community to
maintain new people following that you
have to inform them that what's going on
because they haven't been here the whole
time it's not an easy thing it's real
absolutely and I love like I said the
diversity of streams and the Indie stuff
and I I got to ask you about the St
stationary stuff like what is that how
did that whole thing start okay yeah so
for people who don't know I have three
kinds of streams uh on Tuesday evenings
I play a game like just a campaign right
now I'm playing control I had previously
played bow shock one and two on the DLC
then I played Allen wake and then n one
control uh which was one that I actually
wanted to stream but I had to beef up my
PC
first was like the we're building up to
it we'll play the older games first
that's right um and so one day when I
was streaming I usually stream DOTA on
Sundays and then um Thursday night's
indie games because I just like to
highlight indie games like have like a
nice little wind down that's really
peaceful and just like easy for people
who are staying up late or like have
insomnia and like maybe just need
something chill to relax with and so
that's what I try to offer on really
late Thursday nights so Sunday was DOTA
day the first time times I streamed DOTA
I was just like raging and like so mad
I'm like but these
idiots not they just keep going in and
dying and they're blaming for cuz I'm
the support and I'm like no you can't
I'm not going to follow you in and
die now you sound like addict now you
sound just like
anct I'd rather deal with whatever I've
never played on DOTA than ever deal with
Destiny that's going on right now so you
could get getting on your nerves there
like yeah and so it was I realized it
was really stressful and it's hard uh to
add exp point to King's Point like you
know keeping a chat and keeping Twitch
streaming is like very different and I
think there's a lot of different kinds
of streamers but for me I like to
interact with people when you play DotA
you can't really interact with people
like you have to focus on the game like
if you're not focusing you're already
losing and then if you lose they're
going to clown on you for losing in the
chat but then you have to talk to them
and they want you to interact man I I
don't even want to stream I don't see
like when I'm watching DOTA players
they're the competitive dudes are so
focused and it's like and they move in
like a symphony like because you were
saying that you're a support uh uh
player right so when you when you're
support and these guys is let's say the
tank he's going in and then you have the
range and you're the support so it's
like you all have to work in unison and
I can understand if the you know idiots
like you
said running in the D you're not setting
anything up I can get it the deadliest
people in gaming is the people that can
maintain that focus and still act social
because I I I consider them low-key
sociopaths but you know how many times
like I when I used to play like TG card
games like what if I sat like I'm I've
always been an expert at that like I I
can't I can maintain a perfect Focus but
I can interact with my opponent very
social like so like they're not used to
that and they're trying to not be rude
and I'm like dude I'm still 100% trying
to beat you now I've cut your attention
half
[Music]
like Sol real quick I'm sorry I'll let
you finish no I'll let you finish please
please please finish the Don Sor really
really quickly sorry so quickly uh I got
so during pandemic one other thing that
I really wanted into was fountain pens
because I've always wanted fountain pens
yes but I never had time for them
there's a lot of research goes on in
them because they're actually kind of
hard they're like they're difficult one
right here um and so I really wanted one
I was so excited when I got one in that
I was like all right chat I got I got to
show you guys something I'm excited
about I'm G to take five minutes here
just to tell you about fountain pens I
just want to tell you CU I'm really
excited but people really liked it
people really liked me talking about
stationers like it's Unique people love
it I'm I'm notic I've been watching yeah
and it's just I I'm just really excited
people apparently like it when I get
really excited so I was very excited I
love my stationary I'm so excit actually
have a stream today for stationary at
10:30 um my time PT and uh so that's
kind of how that got started that I
tested it and people loved it people
just loved it so I was
like really you love the thing that I
love that's not
games that's kind of how that got into
it and I I swapped it out for DOTA cuz
DOTA was too stressful to stream and I
was like I'll just play this my my thing
just my thing I feel they like the Happy
brand instead of a raging
brand so salute and salute to the fact
such a unique thing you don't really see
it and I got to salute I've never seen
it's such a unique Lane that you have
and it's cool cuz you got the passionate
people love to do I just want to have
soft catch up on the super chats real
quick a lot and then we'll finish off
this section all right so we have hustle
and motivate with the $5 Super Chat this
is the Lord's Day shout out to Miranda
also what camera are you using I'm
looking to upgrade yeah Miranda's camera
game is very very crisp yeah this is one
that I got from work um as part of just
like our work bundle it's like well you
you have to look nice on camera it's
like okay I guess I'll improve my set as
well because it's stressful for me um so
this is a Sony a6100 I believe and you
have to actually use an Elgato to
connect it cuz point shoots don't just
connect to your computer okay okay might
have to hit up sa in the budget for
that then we have Echelon 7 The Darkness
the $5 Super Chat peace to the Lords
good morning Miranda uh what gory anime
would make a great Xbox game franchise
Elfin Lied uh Claymores berserk or maybe
something else oh I believe there's
already berserk game so I would say
actually a new one that's reiring kind
of uh higashi uh when they cry is also
known as that that would be a really
great game because I think there's a
great well actually it's technically
already a game uh it's a visual novel
but I think if they make it more
gamified rather than visual novel I
think that could be really interesting
right all right then we have JW shill
and this one is a little uh little
messy has anyone seen Jay dub I checked
his only fan page I mean his own
PlayStation page and he wasn't there
blank blank for Cy or Jim dance moves Ry
well I I know I know where uh jdb is
well at least I know where his knees
are in the Box ridiculous I talked to J
yesterday on the phone he ain't scared
of you he got the
smoke what else we got Sol there we have
Gerald Mack with the $5 Super Chat shout
out to uh the Eagles fan 76 Xbox Factor
podcast Mr Boomstick was able to secure
a series X from Costco this week yes
send me that information I send it
straight to him so salute salute I don't
have a Costco's
car then we have tazi with the $5 Super
Chat sup Lords hello lady Miranda hope
you guys saw them koos in the UFC I'll
catch the Pod later on overnight oh yeah
I missed everything most amazing
Knockouts I've ever seen really yeah
ridiculous you gotta give a shout out
to MK yes shout out the store and know
we're going to go over that we're going
to do a little PSA about math later when
we all have them on our face so shout
out to toi watching that uh neck Gator
that's on the team shop right now team
shop pin on the top of the top top of
the thing chat make
sure just let you know it's pinned on
the top of the chat
continue we have we have big cloud
gaming with the $5 Super Chat salute to
my family the iron Lords hit that like
button salute big cloud PlayStation
Fighters we have Michael AKA bedy finest
with a $5 Super Chat off topic shout out
to Arnold Schwarz ner for being the most
used uh DLC used character for DLC
content this year gears 5 mk11 Predator
game and
WWE salute salute to my boy I bontis
real quick you a shout out to D this
amazing crew glad you all got to chat
with the amazing Miranda no drama today
I'm sure yeah you're right you know
there drama today continue with the
everybody
sing continue the chat we have JD gamer
with the $5 Super Chat shout out to
Miranda and the I for hard work and
making your own luck oh thank you
brother thank you so much and we have JW
Zill once again with the5 Super Chat
King Christopher delusional heart
believes PS will have 4,000 back compat
optimized PS4 games that launch for the
PS4 Pro PS4 Pro Plus Ender I'll have
what he's
having I love I love the pett petty
they're so petty today speaking of petty
gentlemen in the chat yes behave yes
please please yeah try to for personal
attacks once you get personal yeah do
not attack anybody personally over you
know I'll snip you that's right off with
your head off with your
head no no plastic fighting cut it up
exactly so what else we got s that's
that caught up y all right good all
right cool so let's go for final thing I
wanted to ask Miranda in reference to um
one thing I like that you really do you
get ahead of is is these charitable
streams that you do almost like a
monthly thing which is really cool and
then also your diligence with Latinos in
the community The Gaming Community you
know I thought that was really cool that
you always find yourself involved with
that so like why are both of those
things so important to you so being a
Latina and growing up with games I did
not see a lot of people who look like me
in games like in games or in the gaming
scene like a lot of men a lot of white
men um and you know it is what it is but
and I was just like I want to change
that like I want to help change that and
like when I saw Morgan we web on G4 I
was just like oh my god a woman m
and it just meant so much to me have
somebody in that in that space and so
for me what's really important
especially now that I'm a manager and I
can like give people work like I it's
really important for me to be a champion
of of like diversity and equity and
making sure that people get into the
space when they necess don't necessarily
have the encouragement or the
opportunity to and I will like always go
out of my way to try to make that a
thing uh one of the things I'm most
proud of is I think the guides team is
one of the most diverse teams at IG on
awesome um and it's just something that
you have to work at right and I think
people are like well people aren't
applying or whatever it's like you're
just that's that's not how this works
like that's not how you make space for
people you don't just say well you have
to put in the work it's like you also
have to put in the work to make
something different like me who will
just like shove everything out of the
way to make it happen and that's no be
expected to do that either that's just
who I am right that's not fair to expect
of anybody else and um that's really
important to me and as far as the
charity stuff goes um so for my streams
I really encourage people to instead of
subbing to me if they want to that's
very kind of them and I'm just
unendingly grateful to them for that um
but I always try to Champion instead a
charity of the month so I try to change
up every month um this one I'm starting
a little late because I haven't had time
to do the research it's really important
me to find a cause that I want to
Champion for the month and um so I do
that because like I'm in a good place
like I'm very fortunate to still have my
job I'm very fortunate to be an
executive editor and make the money that
I do and I can like afford myself and
I'm comfortable and so it's like I don't
necessarily I'm I'm not doing twitch to
make money I'm doing twitch
to because it's a hobby because I enjoy
it because I enjoy interacting the
community and like maybe making some
people smile and and catching up on
games together together with people that
maybe that they haven't played in the
past um so instead I'm just like hey
like you don't don't have to give me
money instead maybe if you were going to
give me money maybe you could give it to
this charity instead that's awesome
that's that's what I try to do because I
know a lot of people do try to instead
stream for a living and like that's
really important and it's like maybe
give your PR some to them instead and
maybe enjoy their work but you know I
it's I don't want to be ungrateful again
like if if people do want to support me
like it's I I try to do my best to be as
grateful to it it's like a hard it's a
hard line to walk I guess yeah um
because I don't want to be dismissive or
ungrateful be like don't give me
money I don't know it helps me get more
stationary for the stationary stream and
it helps me improve my setup and and I I
do appreciate that people it's like well
we want to pay you for your time it's
like that's really nice of you but also
it's like I'd like to bring like
attention to other things and like even
if even if like they don't donate to the
charity I like to make them aware of the
issues that are happening because like
as much as we do love games as much as
we do deserve a break from everything
that's happening in the world we we
can't forget absolutely you can't just
turn that off you can kind of but you
need to remember what's happening
because it's not fair to everyone else
if you just say I don't want to have any
part of that I'm just going to escape
forever absolutely you can you can still
have a break while being mindful
absolutely well said and like I said
appreciate your humbleness with that
especially the position you're in and
that you're still willing to help and
contribute with these these things and I
want to shout out to got a couple
Latinos in the chat it was giv some love
you know what I'm saying but I stand up
I see you I see Sinister I See Kai Basu
they love when you said that as far as
Latinos and gaming and like you said you
know just you Champion diversity with
what you control is pretty awesome too
gu when when Ryan was on we you know and
he he spoke very candidly about the fact
that it's something that when it when
it's something you're not faced with in
your day-to-day life it's ve very easy
to sort of not acknowledge that it's
there because it doesn't affect you and
it's in in some instances it's fair it's
a fair argument to make that it's not a
part of my daily life I don't know what
that is I don't see it um but again in
the position that both of you guys are
in the fact that you're you're overtly
making sure that you address this is is
amazing to me because again when when a
lot of things started happening in the
world months ago a lot of people came
out in in support saying this that and
the next but the action wasn't there the
action wasn't there and and and to this
day it's not there and that's not what
you guys did right immediately you guys
made sure that you you you took a stance
on it and you made sure you continue to
support that so uh always grateful to
see that like I I it was it last week
the week before you guys had Pikachu
Lita on there so it was it was uh it's
fantastic to see and I really appreciate
that you guys are continuing to do this
absolutely just the biggest props to
Ryan for that too because he's been
really making sure to leave the charge
on that and keeping up with it and and
making sure we do highlight voices in
the community that are fantastic um and
so like I I was very happy because I
personally invited Pikachu Leon because
I really like her streams and I was just
like oh I'm so excited to have you on so
so yeah I I don't know it's just it's
always been important to me and I'm very
glad to see more people give that a
heavier way and listen absolutely ABS
it's cool to see you guys get ahead of
that so I gotta ask the question that I
ask all the guest in the real hot seat
time for
Miranda I need lady Miranda's top five
video games or franchises of all time
okay easy number one is
undertale first far away my favorite the
rest are kind of a jumble and always
have a hard time the rest are not not
numbered okay so there is dota two I did
not yeah it was yeah it was gonna be a
problem if you a
sayta Massa is my favorite wait hold on
can can can I narrow you down cuz we
going we that's acceptable answer no no
no no we we not doing that you gave her
the option franch I did I did I did I
just need to ask if you know just got
never head which out of the trilogy or
afterwards you know was your favorite
just out of that just have to ask M
three I love I love it so much even with
the ending controversy yeah I mean it's
a controversy because people made it a
controversy I didn't have a problem with
it and like why is everybody going crazy
go back and fix it like what the hell
salute okay Mass Effect three I got you
and what we two more two more of the top
five games
this is really hard because you're
getting you're getting to the hard Parts
um probably Sims
3 really a big one for me uh the final
what what makes in the top five it's
tough because I feel like I'm gonna say
something and then say something like oh
I should have said this other one in
well when you come back you can always
correct
that I mean there would be a problem if
Halo doesn't show up oh K with the
influence I was going to say cu kind of
between like Halo and Bioshock right now
but I think
Halo lot higher than
that King leading the witness no well
you know why the only reason why I said
that is because when she got a chance to
play Halo and golden eye was first but
when she got a chance to play Halo she
said that she realized that she was
really good at first person shooters so
I paid
attention I mean gold and I did come
first but you know Halo kind of sounds
very profit of Xbox talk
but I got to go with her on Halo Sandy
is that your final answer
absolutely all right final question I
want you to put in your notes key uh
Cognito is when you say Halo I why don't
you put in parentheses right beside it
King Force question
mark King pull the Debo yeah that King
King
influenced and last I just paid close
attention and you know that's it
remind you know Halo was her love
hilarious Halo to right now with her
friend Halo is prevent oh my God I think
Halo Halo 1's the the the game I've
played the most like the campaign I've
played the most times like I've
introduced so many people to Halo I like
you my friend who does not play video
games they're going to play Halo even
though I'm going to hate it because
they're going to keep coming behind me
and killing me and I don't why because
I'm just trying to get you through this
game salute great top five and final
question favorite console of all time
past and present and
why um oh man that is hard yes yeah I
hate this
question probably thex 360
360 and why and look look King you
notice she came up with the 360
without you cara no I didn't I didn't
say anything at all I was just there
watching so why 360 Brandon so the 360
for me was just like kind of my biggest
for into games as far as like really
deep diving that was the time in high
school where I'd play with my friends I
remember falling asleep with the 360
controller in my hand at one point I
think I was playing Fable oh God now I
got to hit ad's mouth he loves fable
just such a yeah it was just such a big
time for me to really get into games
Beyond just playing a little bit more
casually I guess I never really played
casually it's just I had access to more
games at that time so fair enough fair
enough awesome list awesome history man
we can talk for hours with this is
tremendous we got to get into these to
but before we do that S I just want to
catch up with any super chats and um
have U we have the wise old gamer with
the $2 Super Chat Miranda do you like
tww SBI Pence just be eco yes I do
actually I know what that is I didn't
know what that was I'm glad she
explained it continue they found t i c
she knew exactly what he was talking
about look at her clapping her hands you
know what it is the excitement is just
yeah I love it the reason why the
stationary goes well because the passion
you
know know now because you're like why is
she so excited I want to know why she's
so excited like so I I can get it salute
salute see they drain me out of my
passion I say anything I like they
attack me over itom Hearts they attack
me like they attack he literally does
the same thing to other people Everyone
attack everyone oh I can't believe you
like that nonsense that nonsense yeah
that he being nice in front of company
don't let the smile fool you don't let
the smile fool you this man is on his
best behavior for
you all right we have Stitch with the $5
Super Chat jdb is busy doing an addition
to fit the PS5 oh my God thanks to
Miranda for showing support to the ILP
how long before you get that cyberpunk
weeked guide oh man I don't I don't envy
you and the team yeah this is gonna be
work I'm formulating a plan I think one
of the only reasons they let me be one
of the two people to preview it on our
team was because they knew I needed the
time to figure out how many people we're
going to have on that guide because it's
going to be
insane
yeah be crazy okay then we have Eagles
fan 76 with the $10 Super Chat shout out
to everyone I never thought I would get
so many thanks uh so many SS so happy
for everyone that was able to get a
pre-order no matter what council of
choice can't wait till launch launch
week 29 days to go
yeah still get pre in the end game then
we have Gerald Mack with the $5 Super
Chat Miranda Sanchez Game Angel
a we have uh we have regulator uh with
the $2 Super Chat Miranda where's out of
Wilds in that top five man I was
juggling so many games that top five I
was like man if you give me a top 10 you
just solid list but top
five out worlds is a good game but
like Miranda Miranda the rest of this
this podcast except for me a bunch of
frauds when it com of frogs Yeah he is
the out of wild AC like I'm the one
being messy okay yeah
there you go k there you go do that a
alert I definitely had to tell s this I
told you I thought it was out of Worlds
right so I ran and I downloaded and I'm
like okay Game Pass we're on baby and
then I said what the hell is this this
is not what the trailer that I saw so I
ran back and watched the trailer again I
said this is nothing like what I thought
to the podcast that you know Sovereign
wanted to clown me and said it says out
of Worlds not out of Wilds
fool but since then he has refused to
play
it I'm not going to lie out of Wilds I
try to play it I think three times and
it just has such a curve learning curve
that I'm like no i a i i a inv not was
she's like she's like oh really it was
easy for
me because you're a battlefield person
is it like a COR oh sh get him get Hima
get him don't you love how she's
throwing out smoke and I never even said
like get the smoke with the Assumption
man she one of those assumers oh no
ready you shot your shot at him that's
good we we appreciate that exactly how
we do we thought we thought we you
weren't ready for this no no she's about
this
smoke we have we have sh no Elite with
the $5 Super Chat awesome to see Miranda
I'm a huge fan IOP thank you for putting
on great shows like you do I try my best
not to miss any thank appreciate you
brother thank you so much app and then
we have hold on because I did get jump
we have Eagles fan next is that it yeah
I believe so fan 76 with the $5 Super
Chat is anyone else having problems
playing games right now I bought more
games and I don't want to play them
until series X also
didn't to didn't play Ghost till PS5
yeah I'm
offici
sto and I'm like once because I saw what
they said about uh certain games
and I'm cool with it you know but I I
was just hopeful for for certain things
to happen but yeah me too I feel that
same way I'm in my backlog so I'm doing
I'm playing a lot of neon Abyss I'm so
addicted to that damn g game it's like
the third time I've heard about that I
really need to download it yeah I
haven't I haven't heard anything because
I still haven't actually played uh
squadrons right is so is the update uh
sort of smart delivery or is it another
skew C I don't know I heard you talking
about that star
warss it's really intricate it's really
intricate I'm not into the no about that
yeah told me it's not it's not your old
school like shoot it's really intricate
it's different it is it is it's it from
what I heard it's kind of that middle
ground it gives you all of that that
that stuff from from the old games like
the the xwing versus TIE fighter but it
simplifies it to a certain extent um but
still like you have to have knowledge of
that stuff about you know putting all
your your your Shields to the back and
Stu like that and thrusters hold on one
second shout out to uh Lord G my man
from Lords gaming.net subcribe a month
by the way scbe the month had to hit you
with that right Qui hit you with that
scribe but yeah real quick he said no
news on squadrons and then he says uh
review is going up on Tuesday Wednesday
Lord's G down there all right Jean Night
Jean you know what I'm saying I I see
you brother working hard okay so we have
one more Super Chat from uh Hot Grits
9105 $5 super
what I really dig is all of the gaming
Outlets big or small showing love to
everyone since the pandemic will it stop
once we get back to
normaly I I hope not I don't think let
me tell you about that word normaly yeah
there is no more normal yeah um and once
you accept the fact that this is the new
normal then you can move forward because
if you keep waiting for that to go back
it's it's not there's a lot of things
have been lost people lives has been
lost people jobs has been LW you had to
change different positions and grow in a
different manner so normal see This Is
The New Normal you have this point the
only thing we can hope for is adjust
adjust adjust yeah you know adjust
that's it all right cool so we got to
move on I gotta have we caught upself we
W up right now I got to ask uh lady BR
because I know what time is how much
time do we have left with you or if if
you do have to run we understand but we
I'm not trying to throw you out just
trying to respect for your yeah I well I
say this it's it's not acceptable I give
this exact speed I preed I I have about
45 minutes left oh
Ro smoke she want the smoke she smoke
the
smoke yeah the reason I went ahead and
like asked for it to start earlier was
just so I have plenty of time with you
guys okay awesome no we really
appreciate this is awesome oh we get a
gaming addict right quick with the I
mean gaming Forte excuse me with the $5
he
says ad giving us money what is that he
said addict in the chat and it threw me
all he said wow did let me read let me
read let me read I got I got a hand all
right go ahead go so he got a $5 Super
Chat from gaming Forte wow did adct just
get bodied by the Gest great always look
regardless what Miranda said what she
didn't say all I know is you gonna be
showing my CH my my YouTube channel all
next month on your channel that's all
that matters it doesn't matter what she
said it's gonna matter what I say on
your that's right you guys have a
back shout out to wiie be a mess he's an
addict was hoping she leaves early now
yo shout out to Wi me Hood man he's so
points with Kingdom Hearts and then just
peted after
that Call of Duty was like the cut the
cord
thing so look there's no pole last week
question we'll get a new poll question
at the U at the end but uh we got to
jump into these topics y'all so um who
might as to do the smoke first yeah
let's let's get let's get right to it um
you know obviously we have the
PlayStation 5 tear down which was
announced you know we had a lot of
information there and then there was
controversy because uh the PlayStation
backup Pat news was released and uh
looks like they're going to be up to
like 4,000 games 4,000 plus games PS4
games are playable on PlayStation 5
consoles select PS4 games will have uh
the benefit of game boost and other
functionalities now there were 10 games
I believe on the list that will be
listed as PlayStation 4 only games and
um will not be PlayStation on uh
playable on the PlayStation 5 they also
talked about save data transferring you
know most games will support the feature
if you have the um PS uh plus service if
you do not there is a Wi-Fi method and
uh this was the surprise very
complicated this was a surprise s like
it's there if you want to try to go
through the steps tear down when you saw
the actual tear down it was like they
had a the head of engineering te and I
understand why they didn't give it to
Austin Evans or
digital let's go to the tear down for
the tear down was fun oh so we got to do
the tear down for okay so we're not
going to smoke on the tear down that
that's that's why so let let let's start
let's start with L on the tear down
obviously the PlayStation 5 finally from
a technical standpoint unveiled taken
apart you know what was your thoughts
Lady Miranda on this tear
down it's a very tall
system that was my biggest checkway I
was just like oh my God where am I going
to put
that man I mean they go right there
where Mor is where Mor KY go back there
yeah put on the on the cat scratch what
as big as that machine is she's gonna
have to put it where that skeleton
is oh this is Laura Li by the way I
didn't properly oh salute Laur so I
think I might have
to that's lowkey Ash catch him he's been
dead for a
while yeah this actually this Pikachu is
screaming scared I'll hold up to the
camera hold on all right let me do this
let me put focus on but also well well
I'll this talk for you while I'm uh
Focus there you go Focus good nice yeah
so while I'm talking I don't know where
I'm G to fit
my I really don't so I I saved up I
saved up for a long time and I got an
OLED I was like I hadn't jumped I hadn't
gone to 4K yet I've been rocking a
normal HD for a very long time was was
it TCL no no no I got LG I got the C9 oh
you
got salute salute yeah so good you
didn't see say the uh the the C words T
TCL there's lot gets a lot of slander
here in the chat we
continue I was like if I'm gonna upgrade
my TV this thing is Gonna Last me
probably another like six to seven to 10
years who knows probably I hope for at
least that
long and so it's like I might as well
just spend the money and Save up for it
and like really invest in something it's
going to last me a long time
and so um so I think maybe I can fit it
behind there behind that's crazy we have
to sit here and really debate where
we're putting a coner listen I got my
measuring tape
out said okay where's this big boy
going so so over overall the The
Impressions Mora like um you know were
you happy that finally did this were you
indifferent like where did you stand
that once the information was revealed
um it's good to like get that full view
of the console I think that's the thing
that I really wanted is like let me see
the back of the PS5 let me see like do
you can you move the stand they showed
you how you can unscrew it pretty easily
which is it's all fine um I don't know
like these tear Downs I don't think are
really for me I'm not the most tech savy
person like I built a PC but I only
Built it because I had a friend telling
me what to do right so I'm kind like oh
wow look at all these small parts I
really hope no one scratching very Terri
that's kind of where I'm at I'm like wow
that's a big fan glad that they're going
to keep it
cool cool that's kind of me like we have
tech people I am not one of the tech
people I feel you so this wasn't this
wasn't on your top list as far as things
you really car about okay she just one
of those people where she just puts it
together and doesn't question why she's
doing she okay this goes here all right
what's
next is the number on this one the right
the night right number like is this is
this a high enough number for what I
want do yeah
like the color codes like the one 2 3
four five let me get the 3080 uh what's
the memory you said we need yeah like I
understand some of it but I just don't
have it's like I could take the time to
learn more am I no I have I have DOTA to
play I have other things to
do I don't know I write some stuff so
you got you got to pick your battles
right that's right I I totally agree it
was really nice at least having a
digital frown D to break down the first
one cuz they got to tell me why these
things were important especially Austin
as well they said like here's what this
is and this is why it works this way I
like that's helpful to me yes I want to
know I agree I agree what it is is those
people are experts at explaining you
know Tech to non- tech people no fair
enough fair enough let's get you in ad
man uh got the tear down did you watch
any interest anything stand out for you
oh okay okay okay I didn't care about
the tear down I thought the tear down
looked fine I know a lot of people are
clowning on the the the position that
you put the mount in where you have to
like unscrew it screw like it's got like
its own little cubby apparently but I
didn't care nothing about that because
you know for the most part the I think
I'm gonna put it on its side I ain't
gonna lie to you like that like like to
me that PlayStation is probably just as
tall as my uh is my rig and I'm just
like do I really want to have something
like that risk getting knocked over like
because if that gets knocked over it's
done it's over that get knocked over
Zachary in
trouble I fear for Z life your brother I
I just don't like the thing it look I
don't even have an analogy of what it
looks like because I don't know like
it's it's it's literally a one-of a kind
on its design now there's nothing wrong
with it I do want to point out I got
upstairs mine is I do want to point out
yes let me close my mic here all you
haters that were telling me
that this thing did wasn't as tall as I
claim Lord cogn how many times did I say
this thing's huge this thing tall said
and how many times did people quote
tweet my tweet and said he's a clown he
don't know what he's talking about I
want you all to take this L all of
us this thing is just as tall as I
claimed is spawn wave ran you guys out
months ago yes but no one wanted to
believe that so oh we we can't we can't
go off of USB ports and dist trades when
has any of that ever changed like it
never changes a USB port's going to be
the same size next year it is last year
and it this drive is gonna be the same
size next year as last year I'm done
writing no no people really attacked me
over this like all the time fair enough
now we definitely see that the size it
it's big boy it's big boy so I've always
said the PS5 is like 30% taller than the
Xbox series X well that's that's not
true I'm going to have to see it in
person then more and more pictures keep
getting leaked and they're like I got to
see it in person and then more and more
pict funny thing I the funny thing was
when I think someone said it it was like
well maybe the guy that showed that he's
small and
that you know what's crazy like he was
at like some white desk something like
that and like the console was bigger
than his
torso it's out of control moving along
Lord s uh your feelings on the tear down
sir oh my God uh
it's just I just I still don't
understand the design aesthetic of it
like like adct was saying like I'm I'm
worried that even on its side it's not
GNA fit in
my it'll be on some diagonal like
hanging out like
this so it's just it's just weird and
then when you look at see when you look
at the series X and how they they choose
to dissipate heat right you have this
this gigantic space that the heat is
able to be pushed out of I understand
the Ang the angle sort of like kind of
gathering all the heat in one place and
pushing it out but I don't I don't know
it just doesn't it seems like it doesn't
need to be that angular like that was
purely a design choice that didn't have
to do with heat right to me solve I'm
still on that mindset that it that the
design of it was rushed I I I'm I'm
still on that mindset because this is
not an average looking console it feels
like we had to have this out in six
months console like my like when you
look at it like the the thing is is just
as tall as the Empire State Building and
then the crazy part about it is it's
weaker than its competition and the
competition is smaller which you know is
crazy in
itself you know I'm
I'm I'm gon do to
you the camera
wow so yeah I mean to me just that that
I don't I don't get it but whatever um
besides that once they broke it down um
I I the whole screw you know screwing
the stand thing whatever it doesn't
bother me like that's a that it's
$500 I I don't want that to fall over
break so if they need that whatever it's
it's fine that's a big controversy gonna
PS5 is gonna need its own wall mount
that's it's funny that's what I heard on
another podcast like wait a minute I
think this a wall mount for it how about
you mounting
the it's GNA have like it's GNA have
like a claw you attach it to your
hang Savage so so besides that um I just
what was weird though was the fact that
they did it in Japan right because it
just seems like the Western markets are
the market for this now right so it was
it was kind of a throwback to see
something like that from Japan where
it's like we see it first in Japan and
not not over here right um but it was
still very weird because it was a very
sterile environment like it was just it
controlled it's super controlled and
super weird and
and it's just like I don't know like I
it goes back to the what we've been
talking about for the longest time where
Xbox has continued to go into this
direction where the faces of Xbox are
personalities and then PlayStation has
gone away from that and there's just
really the messaging is very sterile
it's very you know here it is and that's
it and you don't have a face in front of
it anymore did anyone besides Miranda
because she probably has more of
understanding oh going on did anyone
even know who that individual that took
it apart was yes I think he was the lead
engineer
I'm just like I'm like what is his name
like he's the engine of PlayStation 5
he's the reason why it's like that and
I'm going into after Sovereign so he's
the person I gotta blame when I break
this PS5 on accident okay I got continue
some so beyond that um I like I sort of
like the fact that the side panels come
off I can get black panels
now and put that other stuff in the
bushes so besides that I'm just glad
they did it finally I wish they had
given it to digital Foundry and I'm sure
that's coming maybe a week or two before
launch King doesn't
agree but I don't think it's going to
digital Foundry either for some reason I
feel like what's going on now should
have been done three months ago digital
Foundry was going to get their hands on
it I we're almost like a month away from
the
console shout out to John lman who we've
had on the show from digital Foundry uh
we asked him I asked him if he was
getting he was just like no he hasn't
got it yet so I don't think digit frry
is getting it at this point but um so
that was like the last
week they going to have to purchase
their own no doubt so that that was it
so that was it let me get these super
chats real quick before we go to King
uh okay we have gamer by choice with the
$5 Super Chat great show Miranda's
excitement about gaming is amazing I
love seeing such passion about gaming a
then we have Eagles fan 76 with the $2
Super Chat panel what is the first game
you pop in on the 10 teror flops you got
to throw the teror flops on it like oh
no excuse no no I'm sorry the 10th sorry
that that was my smoke sorry I like dang
why can't I just enjoy the console when
I'm probably playing uh Valhalla first
I'll throw that on about the series X
talking about series X on PlayStation
5 know is Destiny for me destiny that
nothing else exists y like for free 99
in Game Pass let's go and then I'm so
happy that the moment that series X
comes out
I can turn my back on PC gaming
forever wow I I I've had it with PC
gaming but people say you know people
make podcasts all the time to ranting
for about 10 minutes on how the cheating
is but it's just in my head it's just in
my head all good then we got Jonathan B
with the $5 Super Chat adct got mind
control over dvo Miranda says shut up oh
my God oh my Lord he'll be quiet when
she leaves He he'll be talking again
that's a smokey line that's smoke said
that I don't like this
energy I'm start timing people out we
have Stitch to the $5 Super Chat I am
glad my car can drive itself I'm crying
over here leave the trucker alone where
is Mario he don't want any smoke where's
Mario is there inside the glass cabin oh
what what happened you didn't see him
yeah ask about Zelda Mario was pulling
pulling an Annabel like he had to lock
him off go by Zelda to play where's Walo
for next over there in the corner as
well oh no now we doing Where's link
okay notice that's not the sky sword
called
Savage we have two of my favorite names
ever we have wibo gaggin with the5 Super
Chat shout out to Game Pass for putting
Kingdom Hearts on the service I hated it
but that's okay because I didn't pay for
it wow
wow then we have those those first
couple heart's going to be rough on you
man yeah be rough then we have safe
space invader wow these names you can
hide behind it I think he's talking
about the PS5
PS5 I think we're caught up no we have
more yeah more rain and Forte we have no
we have actually we have Smitty Smith
with the $5 Super Chat by controlled
environment do you mean held for ransom
yeah he did look like someone was behind
him with with a
weapon
then we have Jean Mark Louie with the $2
Super Chat gotta call Geek Squad to put
in a
SSD
Savage
Savage then we have rain G4 with the $2
Super Chat PS5 will have a the flux
capacitor oh my God back to future
reference let me get for let me get for
you see that heat sink that heat sink is
is kind
ofra we got a $5 super jat from gaming
Forte aka the loser of this bet he said
here at GameStop service is the most
important part of our interaction if you
sign up for our Pro card I'll give you
$5 off your screwdriver today you man
he's really in there with that pitch man
go go go go reach out to we we are
caught up we are caught up so Lord King
man PlayStation 5 tear down did you
watch it and in your thought sir he's
smiling very big right now well the fact
that uh Sony themselves send me an extra
screw in case you know I lose the one
that I do get um
oh my God absolutely amazing right there
was so many they said so much without
without saying anything right the fact
when you looked in the room it was just
him and a
table now when they when he announced
who he was that was very telling to me
because I knew it was going to be as
elaborate as it panned out to be when
you have the
master uh designer
doing the tear down that means it was
very intricate and he knows the the
system in and out because he put it
together so when he snapped off the
sides when he flipped it on the side and
he you know hid the screw it's I'm happy
that they do uh you know give it to you
for free to stand for free normally Sony
would have chared you before in the past
but I think they know it's necessary for
this console and they don't want to run
the risk of somebody getting the console
without getting stand and it falling
over and catching fire and tearing oh
my very graphic if that heat sink or
that fan fails you're in trouble because
it looks robust so so so so are you
implying it it's it's a health hazard
well you know these new systems are like
PCS they are basically PCS do you see
how big my PC has never caught on fire
sir well your PC cabinet is large
they're still trying to keep a form
factor and get it into your living room
they're still trying to be part of the
living room ecosystem the PC doesn't
care to be part of your living room
ecosystem so that's why you have giant
cabinets where they have air flow going
in and out and you can look I'm looking
inside my PC right now there's no uh
connections they're not touching each
other the air can flow through I thought
the design was genius right I'm going to
always say that is going to be a large
we already knew it anyway so let's stop
acting shocked what did shock me was
when he laid it out all on the table I
said okay the slim Pro that they're
gonna come out with is going to be a
whole lot smaller the Box can shrink and
once they understand how the heat works
or where they can position different
fans and stuff like that the Box will
get smaller it won't be the same exact
robust size it remind me of the George
Forman PlayStation Grill oh PS3 yeah it
remind me of it and it had all the stuff
there so I I was happy that that
happened but at the same time I'm not
optimistic that they will launch on the
12 oh Lord here we go here we go hold up
K are you like extremely no he's dying
on this sword he's dying on this sword I
mean listen if they launch on the 12
good I got four coming I don't care but
I don't believe they're gonna launch on
the 12 because I see the Xbox in
everyone's
hands I've seen this PlayStation in one
one guy hands and he's the lead designer
is that the the the the Prototype that
you got there are you implying that no
third party has it and that
uh they not even when they had the the
the the YouTubers playing it it was on a
table the wires were not to be seen it
was it went down into the table it could
have went into a PC for oh my
God and the television was there and
they played a couple of games saying
this hold on hold on I got a shout out G
from he super ched you time he Super
Chat I know you don't want to hear
it yo shout out je that was perfect the
good thing about a jean is we don't have
to listen to you keep going King keep
this sler going it's not even slander
it's just you know listen PE be prepared
that's that's just all I'm saying I'm
happy they did to tear down I would have
L for them to give it to a third party
but I see how intricate it is they could
never give it to a third party to tell
them to tear it down because they will
never put Humpty Dumpty back together
the crazy part about it King is I was
looking at the influences that they uh
gave it to the Japanese influencers like
a few of them were like Vlog channels
like they weren't even gaming channels
they had some gaming sprinkled but I'm
just like I'm just s here looking at
like look I respect them for being 100%
with with you their country making sure
they get it but I'm just thinking like
you know the north the North America
Market is important to you because
you're launching side by side with them
right so it's like why did no one over
here get a look at that call I don't
think they have working units oh my God
here we go here we go Miranda's just
smiling laughing she didn't know what
she was getting into she like she's like
I have one in my house now she's saying
you know what that's crazy because I
didn't see one at IGN yet
right now unless you see it in the wild
there's not even nobody you know how
these leakers so when we start seeing
this in the wild what's what's the
damage control what's that's all I see
is the controll I see the controller in
everybody's house everybody has that
what's that what's
that he has it Travis Scott has the the
controller all over the place I just
haven't seen anybody walk around with
the chess siiz uh console
like if you put it in front of him he
just had his head he looked like the
Lego man and his hands was sticking
out huge console but I'm going to have
it I was but I love the design trust me
if you wanted me to pick the design over
the x or that I love you like the
design as hell big that's sof super
chats I go yeah we have JW aill with the
$5 Super Chat I love that name looks
like Microsoft's Engineers once again
far once again far season outside the
Oompa Loompa I mean the Sony engineer
wow wow being very messy today very very
messy uh dragon har with the $5 Super
Chat peace love life to the Lords love
your work guys and is that Miranda the
universe has blessed us all stay safe
everyone say hi Miranda they don't
believe
it Contin then we have Emanuel with the
$3 Super Chat respectfully I love you
Miranda rip the PS5 what what the
hell what what's going on here what's
going on here
yeah he's rip in his future PlayStation
that blew up oh my
God then we have Jean Mark L with the $2
Super Chat the T1000 was Liquid Metal we
all know what happened
here that's funny that's what I forgot
to mention why do you just call it
liquid metal like metals have names like
give it what what metal are you using
it's like it's like that's still in the
art
research development they don't even
know the name yet you're ridiculous
you're ridiculous yeah like it's just
like we you going to call it liquid
metal like you know what I solv that
that unit that we saw that that liquid
metal was was in the box two seconds
ridiculous what else you guys we have a
boogeyman with the $10 Super Chat sorry
I'm late but I had to put uh my son down
for a nap I've dropped my like and we'll
listen on replay don't want to miss King
getting in on Sony in the dirty double
dip Savage and we have family Optimus
code with the $5 Super Chat not family
no more why you not family no more cuz
he said something you like IOP
approved what's
up what's all this P5 slander I thought
this is a Playstation Centric
show play has no limits play has no
limits absolutely does have limits and
it's limit to 10 Terra FL oh
damn please sit down in the corner sir
we have we have one more we have
Infamous of 2 Super Chat bend the knee
king or we shall break them nov 12 wow
smoke smoke I I listen I want everything
under the sun I want to be able to go to
the store and I just definitely want to
do an unboxing right here I do am I
hopeful hell to the
[Laughter]
no I don't see it I want to see this Con
coming out in November anyway moving on
let me let me get my B before we move on
look man yeah
system big big man it's big big it's a
big boy um the design is growing on me
though I I I didn't like it at first but
now I'm starting to see it more it is
growing on me um I like s said I'm with
the removable plates it kind of reminds
me of the 36 face plates yeah yeah the
360 era remember the 360 ERA with the
face plates Miranda stuff like that you
to kind of swap out and stuff so the
customization there and the monetization
there could be really impactful if they
get cool I think yeah yeah I think the
design looks like you know a little
futuristic a little bit like I don't
mind the design it's just it's just it's
just too big got to be that tall I just
yeah goand I'm sorry you say something
oh no yeah I was just I just don't like
the controller I think the colors look
nice I kind of like that the PS5 looks
unique whereas the Xbox series X looks
fine it's just very IND monolith very
conventional very yeah it's meant to be
tucked away it's not meant to stand out
right like another piece of in your home
whereas PS5 it's like look at this yes
yes I agree I
age like a little yeah I think that the
size of it it's really it to me and I
don't like how they color the controller
but it is what it is no I feel you I
feel you I mean like I said I I think
that the the plate thing is really going
to take off they're really going to
impact on sales after market thing yeah
people are going to make it they're
going to make designs I can see like
game releases a lot of their exclusive
IPS you know with unique game plates I
can see see that really taking off so
salute to that I'm because I think they
like to sell
consoles like that Spider-Man console
yeah oh yeah sure we hope that they take
the whole uh approach of selling you $50
plates that you could take off or you
know $80 plates whatever price that they
put on them you know fins and just swap
them out we hope that did you see the
mockup for the Spiderman mockups look
fire Yeahs look fire but yeah now I I
see the potential with that I think it's
a marketing play that's going to really
do well I I'm with you King I love the
fact that the turn down actually
happened but at the same time I would
have loved the third party to do it just
so we could kind of get it but look it
happened it's late in the game it's here
and the last thing is um you know at
least we got the information on the SSD
on where it goes how you do it you know
obviously screw screw Gate's a big thing
I could care less it's something that
you're going to do one time don't loser
you going you can care less till you
lose but it shout out to S engineering
they allow you to put the screws inside
the thing thing so you don't lose it or
whatever that's just that's just the
stand though if you want to upgrade the
SSD you got to take it apart a little
more yeah mean you got to take it apart
but I will say this there's three
additional
screws one thing I didn't like though
when they he took the side panels off it
seemed difficult for him to do almost
like he could have I was nervous yeah
when he yeah I'm like yo I feel like I'm
going to break it did you see when he
open it he scratched the the inside of
the PlayStation he did like if you zoom
in it's scratched
I didn't see that's probably from
repeated te I think he had to make sure
that he had it right to show that what
what he was doing because they didn't
want to cut the video too much listen it
was very controlled is it a little bit
more elaborate that we wanted it to be
as far as changing the uh or adding more
memory yeah of course and I didn't even
get into that part about the adding to
more memory oh make sure you don't buy
one with a heat sink on it because Mark
cery definitely told you do not purchase
ssds with the heat SN that's compatible
with the PlayStation because either that
drawer can't close and it's a metal
piece so I think it will dissipate the
heat so just keep you got to be very
they're going to have to be very
specific with what SSD spec is
compatible because it's not just any
nvme you just throwing in there you have
to make sure it's to the PS5 spec so
that's the first thing they're going to
have like compatible PlayStation 5 on on
these websites yeah they're going to
need to be get aggressive with that I
think that's a huge mistake because you
know there's going to be somebody that's
WR I'm going to go get the cheapest one
I can possibly get and I'm going to
throw it in there why is it on fire oh
you're obsessed with this he's obsessed
he's obsessed but nucle you gonna hear
that you're ridiculous on one side I do
like the fact that they you know there's
going to be options but on the other
side I'm not GNA lie like you know I do
appreciate the ease of use with the SSD
from the series X with the expansion
model and then shout out to Jason Ronald
those those guys they were like At first
remember I thought it was going to be
locked to Seagate so I was like well at
least the PlayStation 5 has the
advantage of different manufacturers but
now we're finding out that they're going
to be able to use other manufacturers
with the SSD for the series X as well so
C just have the initial contract what I
what I enjoyed about the uh PS5 SSD is
they give you more of a variety of how
much you want what what you know
carriers that you want to use like Xbox
is just like right now you getting the
terabyte all right and that's pretty
much all we got for you right now
actually no Jason rald came out and told
you that there are different sizes and
different Whatchamacallit form factors
for the SSD don't try to use that
narrative that you're trying to go with
until these people come out me these
links get a bigger one anyway because
it'll be $500 so cut it out you're gonna
pay the $225 well see I I don't I don't
even use games like that like I only
keep a couple games installed I would
just say that I I appreciate they give
you the option on no but listen at the
end of the day
these things for both consoles are going
to be expensive this is nvme SSD Tech
these are specialized these are not
cheap this is very Cutting Edge and to
be honest like for people who's like oh
man this is too expensive that's kind of
the going rate so get used to that
people are going from these mechanical
extern hard drives and think it's
supposed to be it's the same type of
hard drive it's not and that's it so uh
let's just get to the smoke you know um
backward compat is announced King and
sve have been at each other for almost a
year I guess it feels like and U it's
been a long time it's been a long time
so you know now the announcement is here
um you know there's conflicting
messaging as to what the bend the knee
was and one one Camp is saying that you
know backward compatibility had to exist
and just it at all and the beted is one
and another Camp is saying you know it
has to actually work you know what I'm
saying and and and if a title doesn't
work that the Vets off so before we do
this V is off the bet
I will say one thing before you guys go
at your little attacking conference uh
solve it's okay if he out Snipes you
because you know he he likes to put his
little his little conditions in before
the beted even starts so but this is the
I don't agree to those conditions you
can say whatever you
want at the end of the day yes we did
say when it gets to our house so all
this conversation that doing right now
so the BET still on the BET still on
until you get it in your house I told
you when I get it in my house I put a
discon side and it doesn't work your
your knees are
mine this is the thing though this this
the thing though if he could say that a
million times over if I never say okay I
agree to
that backing out of the bed hold hold on
hold on hold on we ain't doing that let
me talk no we're not doing that okay
let this happen
now ask question let me ask a question
go ahead ahead go ahead back out right
so either way to why won't you let me
ask the question a about
you question for you look when it come
to this bet under my Impressions I don't
know about you Cognito I thought the BET
was Sony would charge you for backwards
compe that's what I remember the ini
nothing to do with what they did it with
Spider-Man Spiderman I don't
know Miranda let me defer to Our Guest
right Miranda from what you heard from
what you heard is Spider-Man PS5 a new
skew so the way that they're going about
it is that they're not selling the
definitive edition is what I believe is
what it is so there's a new version of
Spider-Man MH that you can only get in a
special bundle with Miles Morales and so
you have to buy that together to get it
on PS5 that version Let Me
version will the PS4 version work on the
PS5 though I thought so
yeah so I did the work to like look up
this news that I was going to postpone
until Tuesday like now I was like oh
let's go let's go I'm on
vacation yeah okay so so so s according
to you because the PlayStation 4 version
works on PlayStation 5 of Spider-Man
that negates the argument this this is a
moood point because once again he this
is a stipulation that he added that I
not I shook my head to like no I'm
always said you don't bet with King and
start and start picking little things no
no no no no I'm going to bet with you in
the broadest way possible see there you
go that's bet you agreed to stop running
if you had if you hadn't agreed to it
are then I have nothing to say but you
agreed to the broad V and then in
subsequent weeks you move the post and
say look man yeah you know uh the card
reader okay okay of curios hold on fors
off to for posterity for posterity let
let me read off this list of bang
that King that king is not going to be
able to play on his PS5 let let me read
off this this this list of of this
appalling list that Jim Ryan will not
allow you play we have
dwvr we have we have Afro Samurai too
revenge of Kuma I love that that's my
favorite he said I love that yo King is
he said yo King they broke your heart
when that news came out was disgusting
got Joe's Diner Joe's Diner King dang
hold on hold on so let me let me ask
King this we we have the list we get the
list but so King are you
implying he's a
fraud that those 10 games that you had
your heart set and because they don't
work that defend AR
heartbroken let me say something let K
get his balls let K his balls this is
this is what I'm talking about this is
the hypocrisy you know Microsoft said go
ahead man play your stuff man you got
that you got that it's good
but you I told you they will force you
to and they going to make Afro Samurai
too make buy it again again like he has
it on his PSN like he has it on
there run just to C just to clear this
up King is it really charging you
backwards compatible when they're not
available on the right that's the
question cuz King you did say that you
did say the C reading though King you
did say the I
got I got the game all I have to say is
this right work if it said this
error your knees are compliant so okay
so because hold on so just deal with it
Joe's Diner Hitman gold Definitive
Edition these just deal with it they're
telling you right just deal with it
because these games the move you don't
even
play you didn't play these
games so so King and because you got
these 10 games you are distraught that
you cannot play these on your
PlayStation 5 and thus you won the BET
and little Timmy is
terribly what's going on but again again
I
digress we don't know until we have it
in our
hand Jim
danan did a show and then tweeted out uh
yeah it's going to PC too because we
believe in Generations oh so you trust
so you wa you waiting until get your hey
I gotta I don't trust these dudes I got
I gotta have it in my house so so this
entire RI roll was just to to push it
push it back to delay it again you know
you know what's crazy I told you we will
have this conversation when it gets to
the house you wanted to be messy
early no that wasn't me I shouted outout
out to Christopher Hart I mean shout out
to uh to to what J Bari shout out the
one coming at you next now now King what
other point that you brought to my
attention last which was um you said you
showed me a disclaimer from the Sony
site the Sony blog and it says although
many PlayStation 4 games are playable on
PlayStation 5 some functionalities that
were available on PS4 consoles may be
may not be available on PlayStation 5
consoles in addition some PlayStation 4
games May exhibit errors or unaccepted
unexpected Behavior with play so your
concerned is that also you go to jump in
a game and he just lays on the floor
this this is they they doing the most
broadest thing always and they do it
always they say hey we have back aack oh
we're we're here 4,000 games and their
whole fan base goes crazy yeah and then
a tweet comes out in the
dark but this is it doesn't like I don't
listen I don't care if explodes after if
the title screen comes up you're done
you're done son you're done I'm kind of
confused listen to backups you got to go
to with the DRM backup that they
got this is this is for you man all
right so upgrading the PlayStation 4
games to the PlayStation 5 using a
disc sign in to your existing account on
your PlayStation 5 console to create an
account insert eligible PlayStation 4
disc see
eligible 4,000 of them are eligible
thank you that's to be determined oh my
God all right go to the gamehub in the
PlayStation 4 game select the upgrade
off offer oh okay select the upgrade
offer on The Game Hub and review the
upgrade game offer select the download
or
purchase there your purchase Argent see
this is where your like wait why would
why would you not have to purchase
something you don't own like why would
that's a serious yeah like why so just
going to give it to you free if you've
never bought it before if you own the
desk and they're asking you okay this is
the disc this is part of the backwards
compatibility program once again look
listen to the listen to the misdirection
listen to the misdirection that's one
two this has nothing to do with the BET
let me finish
that's clarify you're confusing me this
is all about upgrade because you have
the disc listen to what I just said you
have said disc in your hand they already
assumed that you placed the disc inside
and went to the Game Hub now they said
download or
purchase this is where your legs leave
your
body where his KN yours you know what
that could be king they're giving you
the option to buy the digital version so
you don't
have well listen with the discounted
price download or purchase
content after the download is complete
you can play the PlayStation 5 digital
game by inserting a PlayStation for game
disc if that game disc is not there you
can't do that so they're already
assuming that you have the game disc and
they had the purchase why would you
purchase something sir if you have the
game disc well that's that's what
they you're not you're not making you're
not making any sense right now you're
not making you're making zero sense
sense right now like I've never seen
I've never seen misdirection like this
before I have to give it to you like
only only an idiot would believe
anything you're saying right you just
don't want to give your knees up and I I
feel you you must you must so hold up I
will say this though as the person who
started this bet because that was you
because anybody who knows us knows it
was you who started the back the burden
of proof is on you sir yes sir and I
will convict you
hold up just to clarify because you guys
are telling two
different goodness I wish I had popcorn
or
something hold up just to clarify what
is the bet is the the original bet the
actual bet is PlayStation would have no
back compat that's what he said so I
told
you when we do this when I have it in
the house and I put in one disc and it
doesn't work and and I didn't agree to
that if I don't agree to it it's like
you're talking to yourself
dude L I'm not I'm not hog I'm not
falling for that dude it's not happening
okay so being that we can not agree
until I have actual the audio I'm
waiting to actually have the PlayStation
I want to do a whole tutorial I'm have a
television here I'm going to put the
disc in I'm gonna let the world see your
needs leave your
body disc error and when that happens
then I'm going to play back to audio
with the video for the world to see you
is see your little screen your little
Avatar going to pop up and you gonna
disappear you know what you know what
happened Cognito this is exactly what
happened when that hold excuse me excuse
me hold on it's over you're not getting
out of here it's over it's a horror
movie and guess what happens there's no
backup pack oh the evidence the evidence
off BR the evidence exhibit a exhibit a
has entered the courtroom Microsoft is
doing it and they losing so they're
looking and saying that's not a good
idea oh no it's looking bad it's looking
bad for the
king he brought the ether a lot of P
that get
registered
fruition that's the side of your knees
oh that's his knees leaving his body
that overy we have we have exhibit B oh
we got yo we don't even need hog today
EXC
but
Char we agree so one Lee was back compa
or no he lost that
knee you going off that
dude making it I
DeMarco
hold oh we got Exhibit C no you do you
doing a j Electronica you got Exhibit C
about to get copyrighted by playing our
own
musicil okay PS part PS partnered up
with square two for the card
reading I think if anyone's parking up
for a Carter it's goingon to be
Activision but anyway you
know my man is down for this team right
here because he's of the knowing that a
card reader is gonna launch
a your back comp shout out to you sir I
still can't believe you made that bet
you literally just gave your knees away
oh
no exhib C JX King I'm sorry
brother you the defendant do you have
anything do you have anything to say for
yourself after
this all I have to say is no bueno
papy K do we get do we get the D do we
get do we get the D sir listen listen
listen yes I have something to say oh
put in one disc and they have to charge
you didn't agree to that compat is paid
for so that's where your legs are
leaving your body
Shenanigans you got right there we know
the card reader is inside so we do know
that financially bank account so you're
good because in games that don't work
there's nothing gonna pop up on the
screen they don't work yeah that's the
thing that you get no reaction from the
system yo the chat is like King B the
knee King Let It Go yo the chat
is I buy determination to prove a point
I do want I do want the I will never
fold we gotta leave it to the courts I
want to chat in on this yes the exhibits
today on iron
Lord's put a one if you think King needs
to get them needs to solve and put if
you think King s b the king let's do it
now C of opinion we we have all the
evidence was brought to to table and I'm
going to have to go and go get that
show Leo says there's a bunch of ones
it's nice that you're G to grab a sound
bite see oh my oh my God they're
spamming ones oh my God
yo it's it's it's it's a one kind of a
day he says it's nice I have to get it's
nice that you have to go get evidence
that I actually said
that because I know exactly what happens
and everybody I thought you had that
evidence before podcast what happened oh
my God I'm so sorry that they don't
agree with you my team is
Legion and they're bur they're GNA burn
with you they bur King you've been
convicted
by they have stated that you are I'm
looking at all the tools I am not
falling for your stuff this's only a few
twos in here it's like all ones it's
spaming ones a few twos but
likeing we all know King mik 4 people in
ch there's 400 people watching and 400
people gonna put to oh my God we gota
move on I think I think the court of
public opinion has one
today real there is a lot no there's
tools there's tools I'm not gonna
say a hell of a lot of those don't
believe in one over and over sorry bro
so look we gotta move on I guess like I
feel like there's only like 15 people in
that listen I win I win the electoral
college man all right we got we gota end
we got we gotta end this subject segment
we gotta let's get the super chats and
then we got to check in on Miranda
because I know yeah Miranda
lot it's the
same like eight times Stinger said this
one brings me no pleasure kid yo I'm
done shout out to S okay let's get the
Super Chat s if you can or adct help him
out oh no hold on a second I'm here
Elemental poo Elemental with the $5
Super Chat uh GM log Miranda welcome to
the realm uh what would you say to Jade
Empire remaster for series X for Japan
and China markets well I never get to
play Jade Empire so I would like that
just for me too so no doubt no doubt no
doubt then we have dragonart with the
$10 Super Chat I honestly believe that
Sony rushed the dev cycle for PS5
because of how Microsoft caught them
with an uppercut during the VGA I feel
they were aiming for
2021 then we got Smitty Smith with the
$5 Super Chat I guess Japan was tired of
running from Godzilla so they created
Mecca Godzilla 2.0 wow
seven we have Philly eagle with the $5
Super Chat stop saying that the box is
futuristic routers are not
futuristic like a
router then we have Eagles fan 76 with a
$2 Super Chat PS5 packaging I don't
think it will fit in my
car then we have JW aill $2 Super Chat
King the PS4 Pro Plus is a nine is a
nine munchkin Tera flop
not
chat messy pixel v g I think y'all both
win yes PS5 will play PS4 games but yes
Sony is also charging for the Spider-Man
upgrades but Sav is more but Sav is more
right public opinion that we have face
with the $5 Super Chat backup Pat is a
great feature but should not be the
focus of a nextg
console then we have Forte with the $5
Super Chat Mira getting a front row seat
to all the
smoke you need a psychology degree when
betting King s finding every way to keep
his knees I see you bro just facts
brother you gotta understand I know this
man for 30 years I know I know what's
going
on oh maybe we have Jean Mark Lou with
the Super Chat era 2 three four five
insert credit
card we had fix the B with the $5 super
I think y'all both went oh no I read
that
already we have face back pad is a great
wait wait I doubled up on D yeah doubled
up we have palash Bonar with the with
the 150 yeah I don't know yeah it's
different currency different currency it
looks like thank you either way thank
you very much you very much yeah wow are
you guys aware that some guy one guy
bought the PS5 trademark in India in
2019 it is delayed in India for months
because of that that great show thank
you yeah I remember that's crazy yeah it
was some weird thing I don't know how
that happened but uh they and that's one
of their big markets I don't know how
they let their trademark slide that's
kind of crazy yeah got some we got Smitt
the fight yeah that's that's crazy with
the $5 Super Chat Lord King's new name
Lord Shang Tsung King David your needs
are yeah I know there gota be a couple
more oh we got a lot yeah we got lot I
get to copy paste those we have pixel
bit G with the $2 Super Chat King is now
King of the no needs L
granted then we have face with the $5
Super Chat Xbox is relying on back and
pack CU they have nothing for launcho
infinite Halo infinite multiplats are
everywhere seriesx better be a huge leap
over PS5 uhuh uh hold on then I got jump
so I need help there all right Elemental
P I got Emanuel A1 I see go in King
David don't listen to their
slander um I don't again I could have
been skipped to I'm just reading what I
can see um I what's the last one you
read s next one is uh the Y G but before
do we have anything before emanu A1 what
what's the last one that Sol what Sol
what's the last one you read oh man we
got catch okay give me a second let me
check my P while while he's catching
that we have Smitty Smith with the $5
Super Chat Lord King's new name that one
yeah you got that add you caught up
Eagles fan is did we get the one with
gaming Forte about Miranda getting front
R yeah we got that we got that wi old
Gaming was
next we J is a shell for
$2,000 back compatibility at launch I
just saw Bigfoot oh hold let me get John
let me get John B F solve Electronica
sat back on that evidence until it was
time to serve it King I'm sorry my guy
but ship those knees on Ice next
day we got from Boogeyman two because
Sony already charged for back he's a
king he's a technically do that they not
true technically you already sold we got
A2 super perfect Shogun is saying one
one for off yeah you still L we got A2
Super Chat from disy King is better is
being
from Neverending Story We Got Is that
four yeah $4 Super Chat from El elid poo
to King's Point there's more than PS4 on
ps4k I'm reading the small print because
I actual one okay that's all talking
about my Twitter I'll read I'll read the
next I got Victor brick Victor brick
that's our guy love that name number one
hitter s start taping them
knees oh let me get blaze let me get
blaze F shout out to blaze CH Sony baby
okay 99% of all PlayStation 4 games Sony
baby I I don't I don't think so oh you
Kai Kai Kai's in here man s You See Kai
I yeah this actually fights for Channel
5 day it's dead yeah he knows this is
how it used to be the house we would do
this every Saturday we got A5 for
regulator why are we talking about back
uh PS5 backwards compatible I thought
they don't play old games now
that's guess we play old games it
matters to us you know so when when when
you have a library of games that you
invested thousands of dollars in you
want those games to be able to be played
you know maybe you don't need the old
Hardware you can sell the old Hardware
but you would like to have the new
hardware to be able to play the old
stuff so I mean it's I'm happy that
they're trying it I want to see how it
works in execution we already know
Microsoft is successful with it this is
what the whole conversation is they they
did it before in the past and they
charged you in a fashion for it so
that's all blaz for 4K has something to
say Che King hey King screw you baby
play on screws play on screw you my guy
days yo I feel you I I hope it does
launch for you in oh my God moving on
look this
is Miranda's gotta go yeah so look first
of all shout out to Lady
Miranda rocking with us all the way
through even with the smoke
tremendous I could miss it I could miss
it oh so much trend this gaming history
awesome what you do love what you do in
the community where can the fine people
find you what you have going on Miss uh
you can find me at Havoc with a K Havoc
Rose um pretty much anywhere on the
internet Instagram Twitter I be live on
Twitch in about 35 minutes but I think
you guys should stay here probably seems
like there's a lot going
on I'm kind of sad I have to leave it's
it's all down from here just
s the moment you leave like the real
gloves are
off
oh man I can't miss that but thank you
guys again so much for having me on I
really appreciate of course you can find
me on IGN and Podcast Unlocked every
week so most try toay and H first of all
again thank you so much for coming we
really appreciate you love what you're
doing in in the community you know even
the charitable stuff Latinos and gaming
and then you you really represent you
know the XO Xbox Community very well as
well on podcast lock so salute to you
thank you so much and we definitely love
to have you back in the future hopefully
un L uh drama
circumstances all I did not want to do
this me on on on the spicy episode
that's all
I up thank you so much much appreciate
enjoy check out our stream if you guys
like stationary hit UPS add you wanted
to say something before next time less
adct
slander thank you so much R take care
have a good one peace luck with the good
luck with the
bet we see on the 12 if they
launch
salute oh Miranda was awesome let's get
on super chats and then we get into the
next topic um we have stits with the $5
Super Chat this is not real bad compa
the PS5 and PS4 are built on the same
64bit architecture where are the ps123
games hey those are in the bushes those
that's not happening Brother I'm sorry
yeah listen uh I love hip hop but the
that remastering engine stuff I don't
know where that came from man I he just
got the information wrong that's all
yeah that's I mean I'm not I'm not gonna
go in on him like
because a lot of people saw that Mark Cy
thing and they thought they was talking
about they going to do all these uh you
know these generations and stuff like
that I'm sorry man um I I know it's a
hassle right now for Sony to even get
this PlayStation 4 stuff back and Patch
so the fact that they're doing something
is is is really decent I want to see it
in execution in the home um because when
they put wording like uh buggy and stuff
it's like they're telling you hey here's
your food now you might catch flies in
there or something like that but um it's
your plate though eat your plate though
like so I I don't like that I don't like
that wording that wording concerns me uh
because I purchased the game and I
expect the games to uh run now they're
going to tell me something like oh have
a PlayStation 4 to do that then that
sounds like Theon right I think I think
I it goes back to what we said I you can
you can be sure that your the bangers
will run pretty well everything else
everything else is is is a hit or miss
and hit or miss especially at launch
like maybe down the line they but at
launch yeah maybe trust your bangers as
the on they specifically mentioned but
I'm G tell you this though if I put a
disc in and they say you know um because
of the developer wants to
charge you
know I'm sorry like that's that's no
bueno at all you know I should have my
game like first of all the DRM crap
that's going on here that people are are
are glossing
over you must sign in you must be online
and then you must put your dis in right
and that's normal we do it normally but
people are not talking about it and the
fact that they said download or purchase
if you have the disc that purchase
option should not be in the context at
all but isn't that that for most of
people that don't that got either
digital console or don't have a disc
I'll be no he no there talking about the
disc that whole thing was just about the
disc console all right so I just I I got
to see what's going on because I don't
trust them to it's kind of messed up
it's kind of messed up because don't
believe it he ain't wrong I'm listen man
I don't trust them to deliver on this
4,000 because they got the they got the
team all lathered up right so you see a
lot of PlayStation do 4,000 told you man
and then you see the the little
sideboard slide out and be like read the
fine print so until you get it in the
you not deal with it listen I'm going
tell you this I mean I don't necessarily
disagree because you know what it is
like they came out and said yeah we have
a $400 skew that $400 skew is like is
like a a Sasquatch in the wild it's hard
to find because they said it to say it
um eventually they'll sell it to you
when they're not selling it to you at a
loss right eventually you find it
everywhere but for right now it was more
of a posterity thing look look at what
we have for an image narrative that's
all it was for it was we will
see 4,000 day one yeah I don't know
about that yeah the only the only thing
I would say is just that um the
disclaimer thing was a little
interesting I was like am I beta testing
your back compad like is something not
going to work like you know what I'm
saying so that part was a little weird
but look they they I've been on them
about transparency they finally gave
that information up so at least in that
respect I got to you know be impressed
the the the transferring is a little
weird if you don't have PSN I guess you
know this wi-fi over WiFi thing is a
little weird but whatever look it's it's
here we'll see on launch and then you
twoo can revisit your stuff whatever you
guys are doing we got to move on man we
got the Super Chat because I can get on
to this next Happ we are good I think
all right cool so look man this is me um
yeah man so in the news it looks like
Microsoft and GameStop big announcement
look like they have entered into a
multi-year strategic partnership and um
looks like um over 5,000 retail stores
worldwide and E uh e-commerce with uh
GameStop they will leverage a lot of
Microsoft cloud Solutions I believe also
we saw um Dynamics
365 we also hear about the Surface
tablets being used by um GameStop
employees and obviously Azure backbone
you know will be uh attributed a lot of
their stores and stuff like that so it
look like an infrastructure change and
that and then another detail was that uh
following decades as an essential
provider of the Microsoft Xbox game
platform and services GameStop has
expanded its XBox family of product
offerings to include Xbox all access
which provides the Xbox console we know
what else the game ultimate know what
from it says GameStop and Microsoft will
both benefit from the customer
acquisition and lifetime Revenue value
of each gamer brought into the Xbox
ecosystem so this partnership hit waves
just wanted to bring this to the realm I
don't know if adct stepped out of he
still there cuz his camera's off but um
let's bring it to the real man um what
are we thinking is AD there did he step
all right cool so um adct let's start
with you man like what are you feeling
about this partnership with uh GameStop
and
Microsoft I feel like they I don't it's
kind of like the destiny thing like they
don't have to buy the company they just
make really big deals with them and and
and and get real close to the company so
like I don't think that this is going to
drastically change anything in terms of
you know sales wise but I do think it
could potentially do that because you
know it I I read in there I don't know
exactly how they're doing the the profit
margin thing but they did say that
they're going to get more money off of
off the ecosystem of Xbox which it's
kind of weird that they worded it that
way because it's like are do you mean
you're going to get more money off of
individual you know things that you sell
through the Xbox brand are you getting a
certain chump from the actual Xbox brand
right so it it's just like and then at
the end of the day you
know a lot of these people you know they
they get uh these GameStop managers
people like Forte they they get judged
off their store by selling a certain
amount of money and making a certain
amount of money so it's like if if you
make more money selling Xbox product
because you get a bigger cut like it's
are you implying that there will be
influen to promote markof
products as as they use their their
Microsoft their Windows
Surface to take your
order yage I could just see now like
well you know we make like an extra
hundred bucks from selling this Xbox
series X and uh you know we only make
like 30 selling that PlayStation 5 so
well obviously I don't know the number
they made but it's just like you then
they're doing the all access which if
you if you if you consider it and think
about it GameStop is willingly letting a
digital version of a a system into their
into their inventory now so it's just
like they're clearly getting a bag from
somewhere I don't know where it is but
they're getting from somewhere film
Diamond this Maximus are really
expensive okay so okay go I saw when
when I when I saw this I said
aha what was the biggest
problem uh for Microsoft people
perception right and people perception
starts at point of purchase M when you
go inside a GameStop store and you have
these game Geeks that are telling you
yeah the police station is far better
far from
perer y why you
got right now Xbox has no games and the
PlayStation has God of War why they got
point when when you have those
individuals at the point of
purchase how do you get past this point
you neutralize them you make them comp
they're going to have a Microsoft shirt
that says GameStop on the side they're
going to have a surface duo in their
hand as they take your
order they're going to push Microsoft
products and make sure that you get in
the ecosystem with all access so
initially when they walk in the store
they're not going to be worried
about pushing a PlayStation to anyone
because the majority of the storees
going to have Microsoft products when
you come in from what Forte was
explaining m Microsoft will have the
front end of the store that was usually
reserved for Nintendo right that's no
longer going to be the case because you
are compliant you're complicit you're in
pocket so now when your bread is
buttered in one place you will not talk
bad about that that buttering bread you
will make sure that that bread gets
served so Microsoft has made it their
business to shut up that dude that's
like you know well you know God of War
Spiderman you got to stop with the top
tier games of Our Generation and it's
only on PlayStation 4 so you should get
a PlayStation 4 but I really like Xbox
and Halo but man all you care about is
you halo 4S and
gears so now that guy can no longer spew
that hot rhetoric and he must say the
Xbox
BR because Xbox has all access we can
get you into the ecosystem can I sign
you up for ecosystem
plan are you are you applying the
kickback it's going to it's going to go
in mosce favor with with what the
influence is well they was about to go
out of business who saved your jobs Phil
Dominus Maximus aelia Spencer every day
he does something to turn the tide in
his favor it's a stack deck he putting a
bunch of aces in his hand you can no
longer go inside the point of PCH point
of purchase is the most important part
gaming Forte will tell you this when you
at the counter you can sway the opinion
of the
purchaser you can say the well you know
um they can have a bunch of PlayStations
in the back we're gonna sell out these
XO we have no PlayStations right now at
the moment oh my God what what are you
looking for you looking for that Xbox we
can get you an
ecosystem you want to get inside the
ecos has over a 100 games right now like
right now get the Xbox it has Game Pass
are you implying that these are going to
be the slides from the corporation that
that these going to be forced to reme
memorize to to to recite to the
customers do we not remember the the
what uh Game Stop was about before
remember when they had that little list
and how they would uh actively cheat the
consumer is that is that far-fetched
what I just said no so I think they will
be geared up in the back all right one
two three Xbox on sale yo stop stop
X all right whoever sells 5 series X
today definitely get a
Pikachu why they got to do the one two
35 like it's a huddle why they got to do
they going to huddle up right before the
store open all right everybody Xbox
saved our life let's go I'm done I'm
done with this man off get the Super
Chat and then you go oh my God let me
copy paste this last one that is
hilarious my God we have
do you got I see this we got JD gamer
with the $2 this is what you get when
you poke a
bear we have a $5 from Dan are you
implying they're correcting bribing gam
spot employees I think we missed Stitch
did we get stitch for four follows he
said this is not real B compar PS5 no no
we read that okay I just want to make
sure we got that okay got a $5 Super
Chat from JD gamer Sony will be starved
of game and Retail as as Microsoft
flexes its muscles an almost in exhaust
amount of money money to Mur G we got a
$5 Super Chat from Smitty Smith
Microsoft to GameStop when the bag is
that heavy you will bend the knee hash
thebook x x no doubt yes off I agree
with all of those completely I listen
once again these are moves that
Microsoft is making that Sony can't make
these are these are Big Boy
moves this is and this isn't you know
you talk about Xbox this is Microsoft
this is Saia you know what's crazy about
that too song like this probably cost
them little to nothing because they
probably already had all this equipment
in warehouses when they shut down all
their window stores all right but s let
for fairness can what about an e it
being a strictly Enterprise like an
infrastructure move as opposed to you
know like these are not well we're not
saying these going to be now XBox stores
gam all GameStop going to be Xbox I mean
of course they they came out and said
yeah they're Cloud infrastructure
they're gonna kind of re-outfit all the
stores with u surface tabs and stuff
like that but you got to understand as
soon as this info went out their stocks
jump
44% that is true 44% like King said in
some way this this is a company that
this is a company that was
on on life support qu Pro yeah so it's
like qu
Pro they injected they injected sort of
this new Sort of hope that people have
that with this partnership moving
forward they're gonna they're gonna
somehow integrate whatever Microsoft is
doing right maybe maybe you're right
maybe it's just behind the scenes stuff
but just the fact that people felt that
confident in in in in in sort of seeing
those numbers go up right when Microsoft
decided to come in and say hey we're
gonna help you out with this right that
says a lot that lot they had to stop
trading that day they had to trading
because they went from $6 to $13 and
they said we got to stop this right now
whole to tow this line and leave that
right where it is and that so you can't
underestimate the power of of Microsoft
coming in and and even if it is behind
the scenes because that just it's
showing you that people have more
confidence in what GameStop is planning
to do in the future like honestly we
don't know what that is right we still
don't know what that is because before
covid they were planning to make the
stores into these sort of hubs for for
for like esorts and stuff like that and
that's probably not gonna happen at
least time soon um so how do you
continue to reinvent yourself and
something that adct mentioned as well
right any both of these console makers
are pushing a console that is literally
built to push GameStop out of the
picture yeah that's a good point now
that's a good point so you would never
expect them to to have that console
front and center right but with this and
making them the place to go for all
access all access was a huge part of
that hug it's huge they made them the
place to go for that because everybody
else Amazon riged on all access
completely Best Buy is also one of those
things where you'll get the all all
access prompt but nine times out of 10
it'll redirect you just to buy the
console outright right they don't have a
big allocation for all access whereas I
think now GameStop is the place to go
for that and you get a console all
access um I just think they made
themselves by doing this they made game
they they made GameStop the focus sort
of of the the game purchasing world
again in a way that they hadn't been for
a long time obviously with Amazon in the
picture um and everybody sending their
stuff through mail um I I'm excited to
see what happens for GameStop and I'm
happy for them Yo Neil mental King for
you he said um don't forget Reggie Phil
is on GameStop's board now they've been
making positive moves for a little while
like is he complicit K well I told you
before when okay see this is when the
tea leaves was happening right and y'all
was like what the hell is uh Phil
Dominus Maximus Celia Spencer doing on
resi F's
podcast then this
happens come on man milon out here man
who did that for you over man he's like
remember when I talked to you with that
Nintendo stuff he's like yeah man I
wasn't really about that like
that so what you light yeah he said what
you want to do right now I see that
you're about to close 5,000 stores and
under your regime that don't look good
Reggie he's like yeah that is true what
you offering he said all right how about
this being that you had that beef with
Nintendo let's push Nintendo to the back
of the
store let's put Microsoft in the front
uh and we going to give you you know the
surface D we going to put y we going to
highte y'all we going give you a zer
cloud service y so you definitely be up
to date because remember they have the
worst
Internet with with with their PCS and
stuff like that when you ever try to
check out they like hold on let me look
up your account wait a
second infrastructure is not known to be
it's terrible it's terrible here I you
have 5,000 points remember the time they
were stealing my
points yo so I think honestly he had the
conversation with a manto man type of
conversation and then you know talk to
Sao we can do this with them and point
of purchase is very important this is
not a small thing I think this is larger
than a lot of other moves that they were
making you're talking influence you're
talking mind share that's what you're
talking you're talking when a person
Works in a I mean look I mean as much I
joke think a lot of people aren't really
seeing how big of a deal this
potentially could
be and it's like I said I said in my
video I said look GameStop's clearly not
where they used to be yeah but I would
say they still have like 30% of the
market and you know 30% of the market is
still millions of people
like having people constantly going how
many times have you went to GameStop and
they push push product on you yo J what
the hell are you talking
about let me finish my St here like look
like you know it's like I said they're
not going to intentionally come out
openly and say this but if they're
getting bigger cuts and Microsoft has
this much of an influence in their brand
you're gonna walk into GameStop and
guess what they gonna say hey we get
this Xbox series X in the back you want
it like I just like the king voice when
he do it that's to get inside this
ecosystem that we have here going on
over
here look let me give a b we get super
look I I agree with you I see what just
say I mean I do think it is strictly
Enterprise move on the surface right you
know that that is literally what it's
supposed to be help their back in
because we know they back in they oh man
infrastructure Le help over there but we
talk about what's going on behind closed
doors right now behind closed doors
normally I'd be like K I don't know but
you know he there's some point there I
mean if if your bread is getting
buttered by a company and that's saving
you you know and and there's some
there's definitely some type of money
transaction at the end of the day I
think there's going to be you know
influence we we they've confirmed
influence with Xbox Alla ACC right we
know Xbox oil access is a digital
service up front that it kind of goes
against the philosophy of GameStop
GameStop is more of a retail physical
sale used games kind of shop so for them
to be pushing that you know what I'm
saying I'm assuming there has to be some
type of Kickback you know what I'm
saying in reference to that and again
this is maybe a way of them figuring out
and pivoting on how to survive in a
digital future right we have a play PS5
digital console we have a a series s you
know saying these these technically
don't fit in the GameStop model you know
what I'm saying and it's like you know I
I don't know exactly how they would use
the tablets besides you know your
standard checkout thing but it it's like
I said in the video I was like look like
you know they they they can do you know
a lot more visual selling with a tablet
that they HIIT all at all times too like
there's a lot of different things that
they could do and I think one of the
issues GameStop has always had is the
way that you know people come up to you
cuz I do feel like there's certain
GameStop places that do it right but
then there's certain ones that just push
product on you that don't they don't
even try to you know poke around try to
figure out exactly what you're looking
for they just go straight into the
pushing products and you know when
you're talking to someone like Rand that
hates Nintendo and you trying to push
theend on it for 10 minutes probably not
coming back so from what what I'm
hearing you know um I was hoping to get
14 but I think he's working today from
what I'm hearing you know Microsoft
products will be pushed to the front
that that that that's what I did they're
running around with Surface tablets you
know I mean we got to assume some some
influence there and um yeah I think look
it it's it's good for both parties it's
good for GameStop financially you know
it's good for them to Pivot this new
Direction it's good for Microsoft like
King is saying mind share influence if
you have sales representatives getting
you know news from up top on what to
push and and and services to push you
know some of that's going to disseminate
to the ground level so I think like I
said it's it's a subtle move that's more
important I think than many people think
and uh we we'll see how it plays out
let's get to Super Chat move on I don't
think it's going to be anything like
drastic like we're not going to sell
yeah they selling yeah exactly it's not
going to be like oh it's a Xbox store
but yeah I do think it's going to be one
of those things where you know when
they're probing you for questions and
they even since even a minute they could
sell you Microsoft product you know they
might push that way let let me tell you
something and and this is where this
really really matters
first when you walk inside the store
you're going to see the Microsoft
product right yeah if your incentive and
I don't know what the incentive is but
let's say there's some form of uh you
know because I don't know if they get I
I've never worked for them so I don't
know if they get paid like a purchase on
Console because they be real aggressive
with certain stuff like I know that yeah
they they get pre-order there's certain
things they get super bonuses for
getting you to do so that's a good point
so let's let's okay let's let's let's
let's just look at that right there
right so when I was working for uh The
Whiz that's a uh a large uh TV chain
electronic store when I was working for
them we would get tons of money if we
sold wires connect this we didn't make
too much money off of TVs and Blu-rays
and stuff like that but we made a ton of
money off of selling the accessories
right what if what if for Xbox
controller you get $5 for a PlayStation
controller you get two
right what would your incentive be right
to push said product yeah so if if
Microsoft has that influence that small
part right there is going to change the
way that the employee attacks the
consumer when they come in the door
regardless to what they're always going
to be pushing right up selling a
Microsoft product because it pays them
more right if this is the case right we
won't find out for years later like when
they do all they little dirty laundry
coming out but I I really
think if they are partnering with them
they're not going to put the competitor
in a favorable light in the store well
definitely be I mean let's be real it's
also they're not they're using the
entire Suite of Microsoft products like
they're using you know not only on the
back end they're using like the Office
365 you know so for all their meetings
it's going to be Microsoft stuff they're
using Surface tablets remotely on the
floor untethered they're using um uh
instead of Zoom they're using Microsoft
team for their Zoom call Zoom like call
like everything is a full Microsoft shot
we got to we got to admit that that does
have some influence a little bit you
know what saying that's millions of
dollars worth the product and obviously
you know GameStop's going to get a
discount on that stuff and who knows for
all we know like it's like I said you
know they just shut down a bunch of
window stores they could have had a
bunch of this on Deck already like yeah
yeah you know what's also
weird they were going to shut down a ton
of GameStop stores could you imagine if
you knew and you got the memo oh you
bought the stock back oh you lit and
your store and then you get the new memo
no yo you're definitely still hired
don't worry your last day is not the
31st uh we're definitely going to keep
the store open throughout the year and
we're getting ready for the launch of
the
conses what would your level of
appreciation be yeah trust me kind of
crazy inside of let's get these super
chats man then we move on to the last
one uh we got we got JD gamer with the
$5 Super Chat Microsoft isn't buying
Sega they're going to buy Square Enix
and Ubisoft just to force the Sony
Fanboy to bend no one will be immune to
being no one will be
immune yeah I think that's true
something definitely buying something
else that's for sure uh then we know
Juno 23 with the $2 Super Chat no tcl's
at
GameStop then we got family 108 dragons
with the $5 Super Chat happy Sunday
Round Table panel sorry I'm late
Microsoft says it loud uh GameStop lives
matter good to see the homies after yo
salute 108 man I see you grinding
brother keep it up man
see yes then we got the wise old gamer
with the $5 Super Chat hey Microsoft I'd
be careful GameStops trading Bow's
crap it's nice to see Reggie finally on
the winning you a k
wow then we have Smitty Smith with the
$5 Super Chat Microsoft pulled up like
big
Navi oh the book of X for my man Smitty
Smith crazy and we have East Texas Alex
with the $5 Super Chat so will this be
the way Microsoft introduced the rumors
of the disc to digital little
program I forgot about that yeah what if
what if they work with them on no but
imagine you know how consumer friendly
friendly that is if they come up with
that and they they they have GameStop as
and GameStop would really benefit from
that too I can see that yeah I can
that's a point of entry you bring in
your disc to any GameStop and you get
the digital code for free we'll see
we'll see how far they go with it you
got JD gamer we have JD gamer with the
Super Chat SAA pulled up to Jim dance
rules Ryan house and said hold my beard
let me show you how a trillion dollar
company does it we walk we taking
zenx Savage Savage Jal big boy moves big
boy moves we have jald M with the $5
Super Chat Sony is playing lightweight
games in a heavyweight world with
Microsoft yeah oh hold on J bar with a
$20 Super Chat that was King to read it
he wants King to read it says okay okay
it feels great great to be a PlayStation
gamer PlayStation 5 has the best laun
lineup can King re
this keep up the great
work ex you know whato J so muted in my
life know he said that with no feeling
he said that with no feeling no J Bar yo
um your level of support is fantastic I
do appreciate you brother even that
tweet because you had so many people
here looking for fake smoke it was kind
crazy and I'm not going to front to for
you to put up $20 of your money yeah
shout out to J party man I'm definitely
gonna read that uh for you brother you
know thank you so much and BX do stand
up and hopefully you could come down to
the GameStop and uh the new Microsoft
store to to purchase your ex because the
you know we the PlayStation's
delayed shout out to Jay Mar man he had
a viral tweet he said k had to play
Apologize to PlayStation Nation for his
crimes you know what the crazy part is
if somehow this console does get delayed
oh we're never going to hit of it there
is no we never it will be a two segment
rant from King and we'll never hit an
it's not even a segment rant like if
they I got put my own video
out I'm going have the GoPro
that King King for the first time will
pull kid smooth he'll go live
let me get I never seen his name Ralph
Lewis $10 super yeah everybody loved the
console Awards till Xbox got a nuke but
that's now all the game industry trying
to s for peace we still believe in
Generations are n yo Ralph is about to
smoke want to play nice now he on that
King thing he don't get the women and
children murder let's tear all all the
wall we got JD G with the1 Super Chat
launch line won't matter when
PlayStation has start their games over
the next six to seven years as Microsoft
buys more major developers i e no more
Fallout Doom Quake Skyrim what's next
Persona Resident Evil Final Fantasy God
a hostile takeover we go then we have
Maroa with the $10 Super Chat how crazy
could it be as a casual ghost to
GameStop associate sees them looking at
a game and can say hey that game is on
Game Pass and you can play right now on
your own if you sign up with us who did
that for you wow I can just see them
like looking at a game that's on Game
Pass that happens to on PlayStation and
they're looking at in the PlayStation
aisle and they just come up like you
know this is a great system I love the
PlayStation but you know it's on Game
Pass over here on the Xbox yo shout out
the infamous the infamous with the 200
rest in peace GameStop Microsoft kills
when it touches yo slender from the
infamous the infamous
bom
there's a war going on outside man the
company say
from we gotel AKA best siiz finest with
a $2 Super Chat Microsoft is slowly
taking over gaming facts I don't think I
don't think it's that end of the world
but you know they they're making moves
they're making moves that they only they
people wanted them to be more
competitive here's Microsoft competitive
like we said for the past few wait they
said wait please no stop being
competitive like everybody everybody's
like yo they they need more mind share
right
wey we've been saying on this show for
years that oh Microsoft's got all this
money they need to start spending well
this is them spending it so you can't
ask for something and then when
Microsoft what it is is they wanted to
put the same kind of money that that
that Sony puts into the industry and
they they they fa to remember that
Microsoft got more money than Sony so
that's crazy if they were putting the
same type of energy out like in terms of
buying stuff that Sony was they wouldn't
have issues but they they have issues
because Microsoft is exceeding what my
Sony can never going to get over that
but yeah that's like going to a club and
yo the dude just spend your your your
yearly money that you made in the
clubt yeah like yo how much was that
bottle service you did man and you told
the bar you brought the bar out how much
was that oh that was 60 Grand that was
light
work here what the hell bro that zenx
food that's what that was kid that's out
of control you don't really look at what
they did like they this dude's budget
they their budget for the
year they went and blew that and
like that was cash that was cash too it
was
crazy play to be named later no no
considerations it was just cash yo St
they had to put it down there
cash I want to know who was walking
around with s billion 75 Billy who got
that who got that in that book bag
walking around with a Louis vitt Tom
book
bag y stupid so we gotta get out of here
Patrick we got Patrick with the $20
Super Chat Microsoft is focusing on
building Sony is focusing on segregating
King Philly got that golden Midas Touch
keep it up yo salute Patrick never seen
that day man man salute man much
appreciate let's get this fin on one man
real quick real quick real quick uh guys
Xbox FanFest is coming back if there's
listen if there is something that's
equally or more frustrating than
pre-ordering a console it's trying
trying to get your Fan Fest and then
hear an addict
complain so shout out to the Xbox team
and money Rumble for making this a
reality so Xbox FanFest in light of
what's going on in the world world is
going to become an all digital event um
so it's fantastic to me this is this is
again what they continue to do they
continue to put their faces to the
Forefront and make them into
personalities and characters that we can
relate to um FanFest is always been
great I've never had the opportunity to
participate
but um yeah it's uh it's a fantastic
thing and the fact that it's all digital
now but the weird thing is that it seems
like not everybody's going to be able
get in again it's still kind of
exclusive so um so the signups start
tomorrow night at 600 p.m. Pacific Time
900 PM eastern time so uh good luck to
y'all C to say that for an old digital
event but I guess that that's where we
at so what do you guys think what do you
guys think adct man what you think bro H
hey look man I love that they're doing
something I just got to see if I
can adct World ad world it's irrelevant
unless oh my God here we go I knew this
was coming the whole show I was waiting
for one here it comes so we have to see
if adct gets it then it's awesome it's
late if adct doesn't get it then I'm
gonna complain next week I know you're
gonna
complain shout out to adct man let me
let me let me K you want to jump in or
I'll jump in yeah um we knew that they
had Overstock like for they because they
was gearing off for FanFest before the
pandemic hit so and and FanFest they GE
off for maybe six to8 months before the
same way for E3 right so you know that
they probably had the book bags and all
the swag and everything ready and they
was doing the alignments and stuff they
might as well get the tax write
off yeah and I believe that they said
well okay what are we going to do with
all this stuff so we're not going to
just randomly just you know let it sit
here and stuff and these things is uh
period pieces yes right so like if you
have let's say the Halo infinite buttons
or whatever it was that were going going
into the swag the book bag or the the
one terte uh uh hard drive you know
these things uh have games that are
relevant for that moment so I don't
think it would be relevant next year so
we can't hold it to next year so let's
get it out to the public in any way that
we can how can we do that how can we go
about it and I think this is a nice way
of doing that is a fan service yeah and
maybe people feel that uh is going to
suck we don't know what it is yeah we so
let's give him a shot see what it h see
what happens how it transpires but for
anybody to get this swag I'm so happy
for anyone to get this swag because when
we get it from going to FanFest it's
like Christmas to us so I I want
somebody to get that feeling to at least
experience it even if it's in virtual
world at this time because right now A
lot of people are down
so to pick anyone up in any form or
fashion I'm all with it so I'm I'm going
throw my hat in the in the bag too and
hopefully you know you know get a book
bag or something like that so I think
they're going to do a real good job with
it yeah I mean look same thing like
pleasant surprise had I mean with you
know obviously with the pandemic like
King said I mean we thought it was a rap
let's be real right we didn't think we
were getting this um so cool again if
you've ever been the one I mean Fair
Fest you know sorry s but uh s adct you
know been King's been one um it's all of
them yeah yes yes King we know me and AD
know that one year um shout out to Xbox
[Music]
yeah Savage Oh but look it's it's if you
get a chance to go it's one of the
absolute favorites of e3 you know the
things that they do for Community I mean
probably next to it's probably my
favorite next to bethesda's press
conference if it's one of those two and
um yeah you meet so many cool people so
many gamers so many friends we've met
over the years Executives developers
they really show out for the community
like it it's something even if you're
not an Xbox fan I always tell people if
you get a chance to go sign up anyway
like it it's it's really amazing so it's
cool it's cool that they doing it I want
to see what form how they handle it
digitally if they doing the giveaways I
also want to know if they doing any
digital meet and greets if they if you
get a chance to that be awesome that
would be awesome right so look you know
it's it's a cool thing it's a good thing
I'm glad they continuing it they did not
let it die and uh you we'll hold it down
and see what's up I'm putting my entry
in man and we'll see what happens but
that's what I got man get can't call my
con maybe I could though oh my
God Savage
get that's another conversation that's
another conversation right there we have
a Smitty Smith with the $5 Super Chat M
off to Sony we would love to Port eldest
girl six but we must think about the
safety of the kids who did that
Savage and then we have Gerald ma with
the $5 Super Chat what's the difference
between the the 4.0 and a 4.6 4.6 7.5
billion now beat it oh hit with the JayZ
hit with that ho right there I know
about
that what's up I think we are cut all
right man so poll finally returns we
doing uh new poll so with the recent
tear down and back with compatibility
information reveal of the PlayStation 5
what is the next most important thing
you want reveal before the console drops
on November 12th the choices are a need
to see that UI and what changes and
features have been added B need to see
that back compact tested on different
games to see the performance and
benefits or see I don't care that PS5
still getting delayed until we see a
third party tear down the console in
their head
I'm at with it I know where you at with
it that one was for you that is the
question those in the church please Rock
the vote when it goes up on I P Twitter
shout out to Lady Miranda Sanchez who
came through the executive editor of IGN
all for the smoke that was kind of crazy
kind of crazy kind of hilarious oh man
she love what she doing with the
community you already know what to do
check chat to replay for see all her
perspective her journey really cool but
we got Lord addict up with the videos
and bet with Forte where could I find
people find you what you got going on
sir you can find me on uh Twitter at
Lord
addict you can find me on YouTube at
gaming addict I want to uh thank Miranda
Miranda man I'm exhausted Miranda for
coming on I even though she had some
smoke unnecessary she had M smoke you
tried to go against Call of Duties oh
Lord here's her Twitter and I think and
here's her twitch definitely go give her
some love yes uh you know it was it was
a it was a good show and we we got some
stuff planned for you guys the next
couple weeks we'll get into that in the
next couple weeks fire but uh you know I
appreciate everyone coming through and
uh you know we'll see you next week no
doubt no shout out to cyber gun to being
Messi on Twitch how will the PlayStation
5 perform on that TS TLC Savage anyway
Lord sa uh very well-liked in the
community
today oh where can if I you find you sir
listen anytime you go against King you
have you have come prepared you have to
come listen many years ago and I've
started this story and stopped it a
million times I saw a man that lost to
bet the king that had him crawl under
his legs yes as king stood above him
wearing a championship belt yes I saw I
saw a man lose a bet the king and have
to strip and walk down the but down a
bronx block naked which which then
impulsed this person have to carry me on
his back down I see I see that one too
yeah you cannot lose a bet the king yeah
this this person then proceeded to break
their only mode of
transportation so angry at the fact that
they lost his bet yes he you gotta come
prepared for king that's all have to
come prepared that's my brother I love
him know what I love about Sovereign and
I'm I'm not going to lie he knows the
exact way to
frame
Lord of clarity and see what y'all heard
y'all heard Snippets of the conversation
I have the full
conversation oh God I'm just gonna Let
It Rock right now because when it comes
to the
house will show up no doubt speaking of
which I'm sorry so I'm continue real
quick yeah shout out to Miranda funny
the thing is when you see Miranda on her
podcast and whatnot like you you hear
her voice and you're like oh she's like
the sweetest person which she she is
yeah but she is when you look at her
history and everything she's done to get
where she is yeah she's a beast she's a
beast she's a beast I you know the fact
that you you all these opportunities
that were presented to her she did
everything she needed to do to to to
take advantage of them and get ahead she
so hardworking she deserves all the
success that she's having so like adct
said go check her out all her channels
check her out on unlocked an amazing and
I I was so happy to have her on the show
today yeah she was she was awesome man
the journey like you said tremendous
KATU remembering some of these bets
having me laughing in the the chat the
old bets back in the day Lord King
holding on to these knes for
de it's not for de life you hold it on
you hold it on brother hold on going
home first and foremost um I definitely
want to thank Miranda for coming through
and Grace in The Realm with her presence
her hard work and it's not luck you know
because we are manufacturing our own
luck through our hard work so she
definitely deserves everything that she
receives and she's a warm uh kind person
you could tell in uh the stuff that she
does and uh just I really didn't think
she was gonna uh rock with us that long
but she definitely did and she was down
for all the she was down for all trust
me I was not trying to have any smoke uh
with her there she was like no no no no
no she was like no I heard the pre show
she was like I want to be here for this
i' I've heard her drop a few F bombs in
the past it's funny to hear from her
because it's like and sometimes I
remember one time they were like they
the show unlock came on and they they
were still they were live and they
realize it and he had to like you know
Ryan will droping F bomb here now and
again was like I can't believe I have to
tell Miranda to to watch her language
yeah on my show she was a little loose
too it was funny but I was of luck
definitely great um you can catch me on
twit handing out the smoke all these
dudes that want to invoke the name of
their
God don't do that especially if you rock
TCL oh Lord you know I
know that um you catch me on doth Castle
X Fridays at 900 PM where you'll see uh
Beta Ray Bill spinning around in the
background K is going to be up this week
please go to lognet and um check out our
great writers that's there Jean is
working extremely hard he's a prate a
month fantastic guy and does great work
um Teespring we have a ton of New Gear
inside the Teespring store and we have a
PSA coming soon so soon as we get our
gear actually we can talk about that
stuff with you guys but if you want um
backgrounds like that and you see uh uh
s didn't put his up
yet
you know uh it's definitely stuff that
you can purchase there and it's print to
the top of the chat right
now and it helps us out tremendously
because like uh Cog was saying camera
upgrades soon yeah so uh we can look as
crisp as our guess oh my God yeah
Miranda Miranda crisp yeah we got to
step our cameras up again but like you
said like what we're going to have to do
is you got to step away from the webcams
and you have to use actual real cameras
and connect them to your PC and as a
webcam that's how you're get quity like
that so yeah that's G take some upgrad
it's take some UPG hopefully the bank
will allow us to do that we'll get to
that when we get to it but through you
guys uh subscribing to the channel
hitting that like button sharing it out
to everybody listen it's it's 400
watching right now 400 plus I appreciate
every last one of you absolutely I know
I know I joke around and I go through
these little fake Rants and stuff like
that but um I really app appreciate each
and every last one of you that's sitting
in the chat that's writing that's super
chatting that's spending time just
listening getting through your day we
are here together so thank you so much I
appreciate every last one much love much
love to the new members much love to
everyone subscribing everything this
podcast does is because of how much our
community supports Us in any way shape
or form absolutely I mean and I mean I
debut a feature thinking that you know
it might take forever for us to actually
test it which was putting stuff on the
on team shop got got an alert like five
minutes like literally as soon as it
went like people buying the merch I mean
we're so proud we see people with the
crest the zip hoodies now shout out to
Tas witchi had the neck Gator you know
what I'm saying looking like a little
Bandit you know what I'm saying the the
um you know the pandemic mask we got
those so again all the support we again
sof knows it King knows it adct knows it
everything we put back into this podcast
to make it a better podcast for you guys
and it's the you you know you guys
really you guys support us and it's
truly truly man is we truly humbled
again salute to Miranda that's all I got
we got some more stuff fun stuff cooking
up for this month but we going leave
y'all with this um yeah before you do it
don't do it yet um here after the
podcast sometime today our patreons and
all our members yes uh be looking I'm
going to put a poll up for a new emote
uh I don't know what the four is going
to be I'm probably going to use the
three that didn't get voted last time
and just throw a fourth one in there so
definitely go in there make sure that
your voices are heard if you go to that
extent to support us uh you do get a
vote in what emotes you guys use and if
you have if you're sub if you use both
you get two votes exactly so you know
definitely be looking for that sometime
that was you stop lying on Twitter adct
what happened about King D lost his
knees you know gota
instigate I'm so exhausted great
show salute D for being messy salute to
Jay bar for being messy too yo chat was
on fire man Miranda for keep going at
you shout out to slowmo said stop
sounding like El you about to get eler
bar me off guard is what she brought up
to kind of like the battlefield thing
I'm like oh my God yeah she went at you
yeah she's about to
smoke look everybody enjoy your Sunday
get to that football we out of here next
week listen to softs 10 as we peace out
yes sir hi this is Lord Sovereign from
the iron Lord podcast as you guys may
recall a few months back King David OTW
announced an amazing giveaway for the
Xbox series X well I'm proud to announce
that the iron Lords podcast will once
again be giving away another console at
the end of this year and that console
will be a PlayStation 5 you heard
correctly so how do you get in on this
amazing giveaway let me explain if
you're already a member of the realm
you're good to go if you support us
either on patreon or YouTube you already
have a ballot to win this amazing
console and if you support us on both
platforms you have two ballots to win
this amazing console as you also have
two ballots to win an Xbox series X so
if you're not a member of the realm what
are you waiting for head on over to
patreon.com go to the ironlord podcast
patreon page become a member of the
realm to get your chance to win a
PlayStation 5 you can also join us on
youtube/ ironlord podcast become a
member of the realm and you will also
have a ballot to win a PlayStation 5
console and if you want to support us on
both platforms you'll have two ballots
for each system to win either a
PlayStation 5 console or of course as
King David said an Xbox series X
this is an amazing opportunity that the
iron Lord podcast are so happy to bring
to our community because you guys give
so much back to us so again if you're
not a member of the realm yet what are
you waiting for go out join the realm on
either patreon or YouTube and until next
time I'll see you